e
e e
thank you very much much executive
session for resources Recreation and
development and I'll go
into
open hearing on the or open the
executive session on Senate Bill
uh chair would
recognize representative Bale for a
motion thank you Mr chair I I make a
motion of it on Senate Bill
301 is there a
second second by representative rung you
wish to speak on the on the
motion
representative yes thank you um so the
motion of itl comes forth um as
we look at the
um
desalination plant we just felt that
this is not something that we want to
support at this time because it t it's
time consuming and it may impact
the
commission that's already in force that
we learned about that started in 2019 so
this is really the basis of the motion
thank
you your to speak on your
second yes thank you Mr chair um I agree
with my colleague um Senator Vale I mean
Senator you getting promotion
representative Vil you know we have a SE
Coast commission that's already looking
into this I think we need to allow them
to do their work um and then instead of
having two groups studying this let's
let the commission come through with
their report before we pass legislation
is there anyone who wishes to else wish
to speak on the mo on the
motion uh I will I will speak I will be
voting in favor of the bill I think uh
uh it's a reasonable request and I think
that uh it would be it would be of value
but it uh other than
that so is there anyone else who will
wish to to speak on the motion not will
the clerk please call the role on the
motion of
itl yes thank you on the motion of itl
Representative harb yes representative
GS yeah representative Horgan yes CL
votes yes representative Khan yes
representative wolf yes well
representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative dun yes
representative ale
yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
Hoy yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the chair no that is 1921
motion passes
motion having passed 19 to1 uh consent
consent
calendar
uh oh yes by by the way uh before I
proceed representative Khan is
substituting for uh representative uh
Healey see he's gone already
I'll close the hearing on repres on U uh
Senate Bill 301 open on Senate Bill
uh representative the Q for a motion
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass on House Bill
second I second that would you like to
speak on your motion yes I I think it's
a good bill um every other state charges
more for out ofate visitors our Park
system is self-sustaining and this
represents an opportunity actually to
give our own citizens a break uh and
achieve some parity with other state
park systems I think Vermont is the only
system that has that parity yet they do
charge an increased fee for overnight
camping for out ofers I think uh so not
only is this an opportunity for us to
achieve parody
potentially achieve additional revenue
and I think it's a a good bill a good
opportunity for us to help out our own
citizens on the park fees and we do it
for a lot of other categories we have
reduced fees and uh the least we can do
for our own citizens
thanks just to speak to your second uh I
believe uh representative MCU or Senator
mugh um Senator M uh encapsulated it
said thank you very
much wish to speak against or for or
against you you recognizing thank you um
I'm not going to vote for the OTP um
particularly because I've had the
experience um recently with another a
department agency that we don't work
with here but the challenge of
um having fees in statute
and that it really um can sometimes
constrain the department from adjusting
with inflation adjusting over the years
um not adjusting frequently enough to
keep up with costs um so I I I'd rather
we as much as possible um move away from
specifying um fees in
statute thank
you oh we got to go around first of all
uh for the first time representative L
montin and
was thank you Mr chair um yes I'm going
to vote against um OTP also um it seems
that the department is opposed to this
bill um because they're already in the
midst of a multi-year process of
assessing their fees and calibrating
their fees and I feel like we're
stepping in the middle of that um what
the man dat and I believe that we should
let them continue their work and not try
to interfere in their own process of
calibrating their
fees um and and by the data that they
presented it doesn't look that that
there are many days that um that are
sold out I think New Hampshire residents
um are still able to to get for the most
part a reservation when they want to
okay that's it
representative ale and
then representative
oh representative
B thank you um in in line with what my
colleagues have shared um thank you so
much for mentioning those points I just
wanted to also mention that um
Representatives Rulo harb and myself are
on the state park system
advisory and we have been working
to understand and
to help advise in terms of the state
park fees things are seem to be going
very well and this is something that we
can look at further up the road once we
have things established
um with the changes that we're making
right now but we can promise the
committee this is a continuing
conversation and it also involves the
fiscal committee and that process has
worked well thank
you representative Derby and then oh
actually you you haven't spoken for the
first time either so representative rung
then representative M thank you Mr chair
um although I as a New Hampshire
resident I would love to have a 50%
discount on state Park admission but I
believe that this bill is very fiscally
irresponsible um aside from the point
points that it's already been looked at
but we you know the letter from the
division says that it would bind their
ability uh currently in statute to
adjust their fees according to markting
conditions because state parks are an
Enterprise System they're supposed to be
self-funding and just making this cut as
an advantage to New Hampshire residents
could actually be crippling our ability
to fund the state parks we also heard
compelling evidence from the C Co
Science Center um about the economic
impact to them that it would be a result
in devastating impact to the SEO Science
Center visitation and admission Revenue
so I think um even though it's a great
idea I think it needs more economic
analysis to understand um how it can be
implemented and still ensure
sustainability of not only the state
park system but also businesses and
Enterprises that um are impacted by that
thank
you representative
thank you Mr chair in addition to um the
the Department's uh opposition or
concern um about the impact on tourism
um that we heard and and how they spend
millions in uh yearly trying to um
trying to advertise New Hampshire um to
out ofate residents and how this really
sends a mixed message I and in addition
to the you know the CCO Science Center
that said they would lose uh they may
have to cut two staff um if this passes
we also heard from the uh New Hampshire
travel Council who was also concerned
about the impact on the uh the potential
impact to uh tourism revenue and um and
we know that tourism is a major source
of revenue for the state so for those
reasons um I would urge the uh this uh
committee to oppose the OTP motion thank
you
representative M mchu for for a second
time thank you Mr chairman I I agree
wholeheartedly with my colleague
representative Simpson that we should
not put
fees in the statute which is why this
bill doesn't do that it actually
indicates a
percentage and I'll further remind the
committee that we have a very fiscally
responsible approach to our Park fees
designed
to be the lowest and the most
competitive in the entire region at $4 a
day that's it and even if we double
those for out of states to $8 or reduce
them to
$2 I'm sure we can all agree that not a
single visitor is going to decide to
drive all the way to Maine or across our
state to Vermont to save two bucks when
it would cost some $10 in gas so this in
fact is a really very fiscally
responsible way to save money for our
residents and keep that money in our
state it's a great idea and it's exactly
what the legislature should be doing
directing our bureaucrats our
commissioners and department heads to
make more money for the state and keep
it in the pockets of our residents so I
urge you to support the ought to pass on
this very fiscally responsible bill that
protects our citizens and looks out for
New Hampshire residents
first represent representative Darby for
a second time Then followed by
representative rung for a second thank
thank you Mr chair very briefly I had
forgotten to mention um the the this
bill doesn't address the cost to the
Department of Natural and cultural
resources to update the it systems that
would allow for verification of um
residency in reservations and also I
don't believe that this um this bill
addresses the the core concern that was
raised by the constituent that Senator
Murphy referenced that said that um the
constituent couldn't um couldn't get
access to the park um because this
really isn't going to um uh this doesn't
provide a preference in terms of
reservation time I think there's a
better way um by allowing New Hampshire
State residents to reserve ahead of time
that would actually address this
constituent's concern thank
you
representative I just want to clarify a
comment representative MCU made this
isn't going to cut rates for residents
it's going to double it for out of state
residents so what New Hampshire
residents are paying now they're not
going to pay less they're just if you're
out of state you're going to pay at
least 50% more thank
you repres representative wolf for the
first
time thank you Mr chairman um I am
opposed to this bill
because 30 plus years ago we set up a
system to make the parks
self-sufficient we shouldn't be putting
our finger in the till and monkeying
with the system and I think that the
fees should be done by the fiscal
committee by the division and not by the
legislature I've seen it happen too many
times where A legislature passes a fee
it doesn't get looked at for 10 years
and guess what we're 10 years behind or
maybe at that point only 20 years people
so I'm going to vote uh against the OTP
and hopefully we can bring forth an
interim study bill
do that
fail um I thank you Mr chair I just
wanted to add that I'm just looking at
the online submissions on this bill and
people wait in from across the state in
opposition there's 30 opposed zero in
support and zero that are neutral many
of them sent in um files that we can
read later but this is communities
across the state from North Conway to
stratum
to Bartlett and on so thank
you is there anyone
else will speak on the on the bill if
not on on motion of about to pass we cck
please call a
roll yes um um just get my
paper on the motion of AUD to pass
representative harb
yes representative GS
no representative Horgan no the clerk
votes yes representative Khan
yes uh representative wolf no
representative MCU yes
uh representative Donnelly
no representative dun
yes uh representative Vil
no uh representative rung
no representative Kelly no
representative Simpson no representative
Baldwin no representative
Derby no representative ho no
Representative lontine no representative
LoveIt
no representative Ryan no and
representative zul yes all right it is 6
to 14 motion
fails motion having
failed chair recognizes representative
Donnelly for a
motion thank you Mr chair I'd like to
make a motion to do an interm study on
SB 345 I have a second second got
it would you wish to speak to your
motion yes thank you due to all of the
um people that just spoke about the
specific Bill and um also the amount of
people that came forward running our
different state parks and is a you know
I think there is a lot of opportunity
here for improvement and I do agree with
um uh representative McHugh that we do
need to give our state uh residents an
opportunity to maybe do
a pre um residence there's lots of
different things that can be done
especially with New Hampshire parks they
had they stated that they have the
ability to manage their fees so um going
back to um representative wolf I agree
that let them manage their fees and by
doing an interm study we can bring that
information together and hopefully
especially um Veil harb and chairman
Rulo on the uh the Parks Commission
that may be an opportunity to integrate
more of that information to do it
properly and also they talked about the
state um ski resorts and we don't know
the impact of what this would cause to
the skate the skiing Resorts that are
state parks as
well let's see who's second the
that representative
har wish to speak on the second thank
you yes I I Echo representative donal's
comments and add I think this gives us
an opportunity with interim study to
work with the parks uh who have
suggested that perhaps this might be a
way that we can get them on their own to
work so that maybe we can get a
resolution and come back and report that
to the entire committee so I I think
it's important it's an important bill uh
to help our residents but we don't want
to hurt our tourism so working with the
Department uh especially with uh parks
and the spa committee that the three of
us are on I think um it's the proper way
to go thank
you anyone else wish to speak on the
motion of interim
study chair will say one
thing this is a real going to be a real
interim
study
this
is the the having all of our neighbors
having fees
raised
is having having fees raised for out
ofers and we
don't is a very bad look for our uh for
our Park
system I mean we are
the we have the park system is the jewel
of this
state
but you got to also realize that the
people
who are funding this mostly are in in in
state and if they're if they're going to
be be come come
uh Canon fodder in other
states for get for uh raising fees I
think it would be nice to be able to at
least say you know maybe give them
charge a little bit more for the out
ofers simply because everybody else is
doing it and we know I'm I'm tired maybe
I'm tired of being a py and when I think
maybe the other people in the state
might be also so with
that speak go right
ahead I I do have a further argument and
that's that we are on the state with the
state parks advisory Council we are
going through these the timing is just
not going to be there um and we are
putting the parks in
the you know H having this bill hanging
over us is going to also not be a good
look and having people come into the
parks and saying oh well next time
you're going to have to pay more um
could be an issue too and I just think
we have the vehicle to be talking about
this and as we're in the middle of the
fee structures being changed we want to
wait and let those things things plan
play out so I'll be voting against
interm study because I just think it's
too
soon I would be more happy if this was
in the middle of the term and we
retained it but we don't have that
option representative of wrong okay
thank you Mr chair um I found
representative Donnelly's arguments
really compelling and I think one of the
benefits of interm study is it will send
a message to the parks Council about um
our intent that we we do want to see New
Hampshire residents have an advantage
when we're using our own um property so
I I'm going to support the interim study
for that thank
you anyone
else pres M and then
representative I'll support the interim
study as well it seems like Park fees
are complicated there was another bill
on Park fees that that I happen to
sponsor that passed and would went
through another committee uh and uh
there's some confusion on this bill
apparently representative rung stated
that this would not lower fees in fact
it would the bill and it doesn't set
specific fees it doesn't bind the hands
it gives the commissioner flexibility to
set the fees it just defines a
percentage and it says right in the bill
that that res residents get a 50%
discount so it doesn't you know it's
very very clear that it does reduce fees
it just gives the commissioner the
department the ability to set those fees
so it's very clearly a reduction so
obviously there's there's some confusion
so on Park fees sounds like interim
study is the way to go and I'll support
that too thank you representative wolf
as we discussed in
carcass um I hope that the uh department
and looking at it now understands that
the committee is sending a message that
the fees have to be looked at and that
committee that you talked about
representative fail
should get their act together and move
this whole fee thing rather quickly
hopefully the interim study can just be
put to bed because you will have come up
with a new schedule and a complete look
at everything so thank
you seeing no one
else on the motion interim study will
the clerk please call the role yes for
interim study representative harp yes
representative Golds yes representative
Horgan yes votes yes representative Khan
yes representative wolf yes
representative MCU yes representative
Donnelly yes representative Dunn yes
representative Veil no representative
run yes representative Kelly
yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby yes representative
ho yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the
chair yes that is 19 to one motion
passes there will not be a Minority
Report
uh I'm not certain well we can go to
necessarily to consent because it is a
an early Bill and uh it does have fees
in it but we can try why don't we try to
consent and see what happens let
the but yes consent
but sometimes you know you don't know
all right um well in House Bill
345 and that that is an early bill so
that's got to get out of here
387 FN on the pilot
pass uh representative U mugh do you
have a a motion thank you Mr
chairman on this park fee bill I'll move
interim study as
well is there is there a
second I'll second Mr chair second by
representative harb you wish to speak to
your motion thank you Mr chairman we
heard compelling testimony for the need
uh to have some increased access to the
state parks um but we did hear that the
the revenue source for this was
questioned as far as grants and how long
and what how exactly the passes would be
administered would it be for one person
or for a bus load how long the pass
would be good for um so with all of that
and considering that we now have some
work to do on park passes with a genuine
inter room study my suggestion is that
we roll This in with the other inter
room study and study the two together I
mean obviously there'll be their
separate bills and separate interim
studies but could meet on the same day
at the same time with the same
stakeholders so it seems like on Park
fees interim study is the way to go for
this bill and this committee so I urge
the committee to support interim study
and uh on on the second do you wish to
speak very briefly thank you Mr chair uh
I agree with my fellow representative
with those comments uh I also think that
there was some questions that I had
concerning the length of the pilot the
actual how the program would work uh
funding um that's why I support we need
to look at this some more and I support
the interim study thank
you representative wolf
I think my comments have been uh stated
by representative harb representative
McHugh and let's put the whole package
together representative R yeah I'm going
to oppose the interm study this bill
doesn't have anything to do with fees
this has to do with collecting data on
the usage and the benefits of enabling
people that our clients of mental health
centers in the state there's only 30 of
them um to be able to access the parks
to confirm to collect data and confirm
existing research that um this type of
encounter between people suffering
mental illness and nature actually helps
them recover um from their disease and I
think that with the
very um you know our mental health
system in New Hampshire has room for
improvement and this may be an extreme
ex costeffective way for us to support
those patients um it says right in the
bill it's a three-year pilot program so
it's not going to extend beyond that it
has the support of the state parks it's
not going to cost them any money extra
there it's it's going to work like a
library pass system like I can go to the
maraman public library I can get passes
to a lot of various things um and if and
and I'm able to enjoy it and people that
can afford to pay for those passes they
can check them out of the library that's
what this is It's a library check
checkout program for a pass um and I and
the park system did say that after the
three-year pilot they would assess if
the program is successful then there
would be a charge so this isn't
something that is a permanent program
it's threee start to finish and I think
the data that we can collect for it is
going to be very very valuable in
informing us in our Mental Health
Services pres
Veil thank you Mr chair I'm going to
join my colleague representative rang in
my other hat I'm a long-term mental
health Advocate who's worked for um
hospitals and in major mental health
centers for the past 30 years and I feel
like this is a really good step in the
right direction for um helping us to
understand that mental illness is
everybody's problem
and that The Cure is
everybody's obligation and this is a way
for us to be able to provide what can be
considered part of a person's treatment
and that is outdoor recreation it is a
place you know we're talking about
facilities that where you can really
roam free and these things are critical
to helping people get across that divide
that's standing between them and
sobriety or them and a long-term mental
illness Complicated by chemical
dependency so I will um be opposing the
interim study because I think that this
is something that we could have another
motion on um the parks does support it
and they're also saying they can
operationalize it so that's my argument
thank
you else representative M second thank
you Mr chairman this bill
is make no mistake about fees for Park
systems I heard from my colleague
representative rung that this was about
collecting
data the bill says it's fees for Park
systems it in fact in line four directs
the commissioner of the Department of
Natural and cultural resources to shall
establish in its fee
package a three-year pilot program to I
quote provide one or more passes to
state parks for each participating
Center we don't know how many centers we
don't know where the money's coming from
it's an unfunded another unfunded social
program from some mystery state and
federal grants based on some mystery
available funds and donations and I'm
quoting right out of the bill so this is
not a data collection bill this is a
state park fee Bill and in fact it goes
a several steps further than the last
state park bill it mandates free passes
from some unknown source of money for
some unknown number of
centers it's we all know that mental
health is a huge problem this doesn't
solve that problem this forces our
commissioner to give out free passes
from some unknown bucket and it's
probably a good idea but it needs to be
studied until we figure out where the
money's coming from how much it is and
the only thing we actually know is that
it's three years that's the only
definitive thing in it so the right
thing to do is to study it if we're not
willing to give a $2 discount to our
citizens but we are willing to give a
blank check to an unknown number of
people what are we doing right it just
makes sense this is born for interim
study along with the other fees so come
on interim study this bill with the
other state park fee bill that's the
right thing to do that's a sensible
thing to do and I hope I could clarify
the actual language in the actual bill
it's a state park fee bill with a
directive a sh to the
commissioner
derbyan thank you Mr chair if I'm
smiling it's not because I'm laughing I
promise I'm just I thought that was a
compassionate argument that you made um
I I do want to point out this bill is
actually very well bounded um you
there's some other points that you made
that I don't disagree with but this bill
is very well bounded there are 30 um
Community me mental health C centers
targeted 20 recovery centers 10 um
Community Mental Health Centers and this
um and the the program that this is
based off of already has sort of an
established cost so the the B the cost
to the for the passes is very well known
and it's not arbitrary um
I I will not be supporting um the
interim study because I believe that
mental health is very important in the
state and this is a a step um towards
that um so I I hope that we can move
towards an utop pass but um I just
wanted to reinforce that the costs are
well known for
this okay representative Harvey
boo well um at the bottom of the bill it
says that due to time constraints there
unable to provide a fiscal note um as
introduced um I just would like to note
that I believe that libraries are Town
libraries pay for their Library passes
as a library they have the
subscription I believe the I think this
is the idea behind the bill is is
wonderful and I would love to see more
people um in mental health programs
access our parks and I support the idea
possibly through interim study um
enabling that in the same way that
libraries get subscriptions I just want
to make sure it's fair across the board
since we already have our libraries
paying for their passes I believe this
possibly uh expand the program a little
bit more to include these sort of groups
thanks representive ran thank you Mr
chair uh my concern is where does it
stop um so I I'm totally for mental
health and recovery centers I was a
mental health worker for 20 years
however um the next group could be um
underfunded um daycares um the next
group could be um Wounded Warrior I
don't I don't know where does this where
does it end that the next pilot program
and the next I I volunteer for a
homeless teens program why can't we get
passes um as the um fiscal
responsibility to our Parks I'm not sure
where the end is that's my biggest
concern representative
run thank you um not withstanding the
the speech of my colleague from miramac
um this is very clear it's not this is
not a fee they're just offering the
current day use one day use past to 30
Community Mental Health Centers um I
think for the cost of this compared to
the cost we spend on Mental Health this
is actually a very economical way to
address the needs of our citizens
suffering from mental health disease and
I'd also like to remind people we had
compelling testimony from the state and
from Nami and if you read if you read
their written
testimony this bill I'm surprised it's
even controversial it should be
something that should be easily passed
to support these people and learn from
this pilot whether um day use passes can
be continued for these centers at a cost
which was estimated at $105 per year
thank
you anyone
else I do want to make a make a comment
or two uh we did hear a lot from uh
from people as
to what would the the
extent what would the this pass cover
would it recover would it cover one
person would it recover two people five
people and would well what would how
would it be uh how would it be
implemented would somebody have to go
with that person would that mean that
per the whoever went with that person
have to get a pass as well it was also
even talked about what about a bus load
of people for every so everyone can go
there what how would that be covered
there were all of those things that had
not yet been worked out and
discussed U and that was my that is one
of the big issues to get this thing
before a an interim study
committee and also I mean I just want
when I hear that this is a data
collection scientific
study if we had a data collection of
free ice cream for people and we all
found that everybody liked free ice
cream except for the one
person it would would that justify the
same kind of behavior this is going out
in the park is like free ice cream it's
nice it's great I agree I don't think
you need a study for that to know that
having people in the park is is
great issue in with this is how do you
pay for it and who should pay for it
realizing that the person entering the
park is
subsidizing that issue subsidizing that
other person who's coming in at a
discount or free and that I think is
something that we want we want to
discuss you know similar to what
representative Ryan said what about all
of the other things so that's what I'm
saying I support the
inter at that see no one else somebody
wants to step on m
word uh will the clerk please call the
role on interim study
yes thank you on interim study
representative harb yes representative
ghouls yes representative Horgan yes CL
votes yes representative Khan yes
representative wolf representative MCU
yes representative donelly yes
representative Dunn yes Representative
veale no representative rung no
representative Kelly no representative
Simpson no representative Baldwin no
representative Derby no
representative ho no representative l
montine no representative lit no
representative Ryan
yes and the chair yes that's 11
to9
passes to
n consent only only
King okay
okay representative mugh for the uh for
the
majority and
representative Veil for the
minority
okay close close the hearing
on 387
uh on House
Bill
474 digging on state property or
treasure hunting on state
property4 representative representative
Veil for a
motion I make a motion of itl on Senate
Bill 474
is there a
second second
by you wish to speak on your uh on your
M representative there yes um so just
quickly the um I the itl motion just
comes from the fact that um we learned
that municipalities often have the
jurisdiction over the athletic fields
and so they can restrict um treasure
hunting by metal detecting there um and
we also heard that in terms of State
lands um the example that was brought up
was Plymouth State University and the
university grounds although they may be
State
Property we again there are already
methods in place and people are not
allowed to treasure hunt on that
property so for that reason I think
right now um the best motion is a motion
of inexpedient to
legislate pres rung to speak to your
second I
agree that
is is there anyone else who wishes to
speak on the motion
see not I will just say that I uh I I
will be voting against the motion of itl
I think uh State Property uh
is treated somewhat differently I think
uh people seem to feel that state
property is their is the people's
property and they have rights on it so
unless you have specifically our
are uh but have statutes on what you can
and can't do then uh uh it's you're
there there is there are issues involved
that that's why I would support this
bill as it exists
so with
that any no one else speak on the motion
no you want to step on my well no I I'm
just confused by what you said so
because this will Lim limit the Public's
access to State prop that's right it
will put it will limit the Public's
access
statutorily right now if it's not in
statute they feel that they have a right
for to access to that
property some people
do if you don't know though who they are
I
do will the clerk please call the role
oh have excuse
me representative Khan
thank you Mr chairman because I'm U
substituting representative so and I'm
going to vote I just need to know that
if it's going to affect my uh District
sebr uh many of you probably do not know
that uh sebr Beach is the owned by sebr
taxpayers not the state of New Hampshire
is this the way we going to vote today
is it going to affect anything on the C
Beach to do this bill specifically is uh
uh res is for State Property thank you
Mr
chairman being that cour please call the
role yes gladly representative harb yes
representative G yes representative
Horgan yes cler votes yes representative
Khan yes representative wolf yes
representative
mugh yes representative Donnelly yes yes
representative dun yes representative
Veil yes representative rung yes
representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the chair no that is 1921
passes consent
consent now go to
uh well close the hearing on
474 open a hearing on
492 concerning uh the waste
water representative rung thank you Mr
chair I move uh to pass on 4 house uh
Senate Bill 492
we have a
second s by second by representative
vilici to speak to your motion yes thank
you Mr chair um this bill has three
components to it um and primarily their
housekeeping one is to remove the term
interconnecting from statute when
referring to sewers because it prevents
municipalities from accessing Monies to
improve their sewer infrastructure
because intercepting isn't a term that's
consistent with state grants and even
and it's part of the sewer system it's
just a glitch that we need to fix so
that our cities and towns can get help
with these infrastructure projects the
other thing it does is it increases the
fee for certification of uh Wastewater
operators um that last the $50 fee
that's currently in effect has been in
effect for about 25 years it doesn't
cover the cost of this self-funding
program this training center so in order
to keep this training center operating
um and in in the administration we need
to increase the fee there was no um
opposition by anyone that takes part
they they want this fee because they
want this training and certification and
then the third thing it does is it
clarifies that Dees certifies
engineering firms that do
in this type of infrastructure work
rather than um Wastewater Engineers um
we have the office of professional lure
which already certifies that profession
um but um the changes in this bill make
it clear that when Dees is compiling a
list of valid firms that it is firms and
not just an individual engineer engineer
I hope I didn't make it more confusing
but that's the three things that spill
does
wish speak your
second only to say I I believe my
colleague covered um the reasons why I
would also support the
bill representa representative Derby for
thank you Mr chair um I support this
bill because what we learned is that
this um the state aid um Grant already
covers um the systems but the this
language um adds to the to the time
delays that it takes to approve these um
those time delays can actually have
significant impacts in um in when
municipalities uh are are making grants
to to for the municipal water system or
Municipal system improvements so this is
actually an important bill in order to
improve efficiency and support our
municipalities um and and the the
there's no except for the minor fee
change that uh representative rang
mentioned there's no change in in cost
from the state's
perspective um in addition to what um
representative rang said about uh
the the request from the people that
will be charged this fee to to pay it so
that they can actually get their
training facilities upgraded which
ultimately will result uh result in more
efficient training and less cost overall
by the municipalities because more less
time away um from the work they actually
have to do there also is the elimination
of a penalty fee so there's a um there's
a you know a slight fee increase but
there's also a penalty fee elimination
um overall I think it's it's an really
important bill to help our
municipalities and I hope that the
committee votes and support of the OTP
motion thank
you any other any
other comments or
questions this simply that the chair
will not be voting in favor of this bill
be because the fee still exists so and I
did not get any uh it was said in
testimony that uh
the people who got the fee like liked it
or wanted to have it increased I did not
get any information onto that other than
verbal so I will be voting against the
bill
uh with that will the police will the
cler Polie call the rooll
on on the bill on Senate Bill
492 motion of a to pass rep
for which one we're 492 right
492 492 okay yep 492 representative harb
yes
representative GS yes representative
Horgan
no uh clerk votes yes uh representative
Khan
yes uh one two just okay representative
wolf yes okay representative Miku yes
representative Donnelly yes
representative Dunn yes representative
Vale
yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
ho yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the chck
no that is 17 to two motion
passes can't be two
this
TW who we miss 18 to
two oh put myself down sorry
okay 18 yeah 18 to two
sorry going to be a minority or uh well
is it's can't be on consent because it
has a fee in it so it will go to the
floor uh but there was be no Minority
Report
okay okay that
passes and now we go
to
589 that bill 589
49 excuse oh yeah excuse
me
okay do I have
a
49 representative Derby for a motion
thank you Mr chair I'd like to make a
motion of ought to pass on Senate Bill
549 a second
second by representative Vale wish to
speak on your motion yes Mr chair thank
you um we heard testimony How are um
this dams across the state are
critically underfunded which are which
uh requires um funding maintenance um
and repairs from the general funds um
this bill will set up a committee that
will seek funding options um that will
seek options to both uh increase the
funding avail ailable as well as other
maintenance and um operation support in
addition um it another important Clause
of this bill is that it um permits the
Department of Environmental Services um
to appropriately uh classify reclassify
dams um if they uh if there's a risk of
that their design um no longer meets the
let me say it differently if there's a
um if the design no longer meets the
risk that would be um of cat of dam
failure basically allows these to be
marked as uh Hazard classification um
that's an that's an important aspect
because it um there are State there
right now um the dams can only be
reclassified if there's Downstream
changes um and it doesn't and it and
there are high high Hazard dams that
aren't correctly classified as such so
I'd urge the um committee to um uh vote
with me ought to pass on this thank
you representative Bale and just to
reinforce um the reclassification part
of this bill is really critical and um I
hope that people will vote a to
pass there anyone else wishes to speak
on the
bill if not the court please call the
rooll
yes on the motion of a to pass Senate
Bill
549 representative harp yes
representative GS yes representative
Horgan yes CL votes yes representative
Khan yes representative wolf yes
representative MCU yes representative
donelly yes representative dun yes
representative
Vale yes representative rung yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby yes representative
hoit yes representative L montine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan yes and the chair yes that is pass
unanimously moving right
along
uh right
that on that y there'll be in consent it
20 nothing 20 nothing 20 nothing I think
that's that's a
consent has
that uh no I don't I don't think that
that does like I say
let's let's do it and you
know better
than better to uh better to to just ask
forgiveness than to then to ask
permission
okay House Bill 589 last one on the on
this list uh representative M for a
thank you Mr chairman I move ought to
pass on Senate Bill 589 out to pass open
second by repres
representative representative dun and
representative
Darby for an amendment thank you Mr
chair yes I'd like to um move Amendment
um uh
2024-25
95h seconded by representative
run is you like to speak to your
Amendment yes thank you Mr chair this
this amendment makes a an incredibly
trivial change um to the language of the
bill which simply Mo removes the
restriction
that this bill only applies to towns and
in in particular does not apply to
cities there no are no other options in
statute to provide intermunicipal
agreements where cities can benefit in a
similar manner um as provided in this
bill and this the the language from this
bill explicitly included currently
includes prior to this amendment a
clause that restricts it to only
towns including cities um in the these
agreements will encourage intermunicipal
collaboration which was stated as a side
benefit of
testimony um without this it will
continue to pit cities against towns
which we see and and having more sort of
C collaborative um intermunicipal uh
Arrangements will benefit all the
citizens of New
Hampshire these
um cities likely can develop waste Water
Systems especially with the um in with
the increasing increasingly challenging
uh requirements for example of recent
past changes that could support not only
the city um but also towns um and the
towns would benefit by not having to uh
build uh develop these
independently the um when asked um of
the dairy Town counselor when he
testified why this um why this charge
was in place he's said reasonably it's
because um the towns want to to benefit
um from the sir charge for non septic
related uh measures in in the fairness
that we have in this state that that
benefit should also apply to
cities currently the mod the language
that this was um based off of which is
for um intermunicipal um water
agreements only applies to a single town
and it's that same single town that is
the only um this will only benefit two
towns in the entire State we're not
actually um it's not good practice to
pass legislation that benefits one town
but I'm wholeheartedly in support of of
supporting it if um it uh if we could
encourage better intermunicipal
cooperation by including cities in this
otherwise I'll be forced to vote against
the unamended bill I urge my colleagues
to um support this amendment thank
you anyone wish to uh speak in support
of the of the
amendment thank you Mr chair I'll speak
to my second um I think by including
cities in this and giving cities the
ability to do a SE charge it recognizes
that their taxpayers too make a
significant contribution when they're
building sewer Wastewater infrastructure
and they should be able to benefit from
that sear charge that you know it and it
saves towns uh town taxpayers from
having to make that investment of a
sewer system when they can hook into a
city so um I I support that we strike
the language that only limits this to
towns that we expand it to cities so
that all property taxpayers can reap the
benefits of the investment they make in
this type of infrastructure
anyone wish to speak represent
representative
veale yes um without the amendment um
for the reasons that have been given by
my colleagues um this wouldn't I
wouldn't be able to vote for this
because cities against towns is very
difficult with being in a city
particularly and this will be helpful
thank you representative Darby for
bringing forward the
amendment representative wolf do you
have you have your mic on is no okay I
thought we were signaling that you have
you on is there uh anyone who wishes to
speak uh on the amendment representative
donelly um I'm unsure of this amendment
because we have no testimony from anyone
that's running municipal or uh City s
systems um I'm not an expert and I don't
know if anyone else in the room is an
expert on on what does this Amendment
how does this impact cities how does
this impact um our existing cities with
water treatment plants because right now
this is uh strictly going after um the
other bill as it is is allowing for all
towns to work with cities this is now
allowing correct me if I'm wrong cities
to work with cities and I don't
understand the impact of what this
amendment may have and we have no
expertise no expert witnesses to help us
with this
representative Derby thank you Mr chair
just in response to the question this is
enabling legislation which allows
intermunicipal agreements intermunicipal
agreements have to be approved by all
the municipalities
involved um the specific language
strikes a clause that says um for
municipalities governed by a particular
RSA which which uh limits it to towns so
by eliminating that Clause it allows
towns to work with towns towns to work
with cities and cities to work with
cities although there are no as far as I
know in the state not many adjacent
cities at least not um not in the south
central part of the state um so uh this
is only enabling legislation legislation
and has to be approved by the um
municipalities where it where those
intermunicipal agreements would be put
in place
representative har going to speak
against the amendment I am concerned on
two fronts the first one is it would
change what the Senate sent I think it's
an important bill as written that should
be passed as written secondly I don't
really see it a major event with a city
interconnecting with another city since
I am told most cities already have their
own septic U or sewer systems so the
there wouldn't be a need for them to do
it I want to see the bill passed I think
we have the best chance to have it
passed overall as written thank
you representative
KH thank you Mr chairman again I because
I was not on the public hearing and lack
of knowledge about my uh about this
amendment uh my question to
representative Derby that uh uh the town
of sebr when I was the
selectman for years we had discussion
with the Hampton Falls that they want to
tie into SE Brook sewer system how it
affects now let me let me go back a
little bit this town of SE Brook um
asked that they will have a different
rate than cbook residents how this
amendment affects that uh um SE Brook if
uh SE Brook asking for different rates
thank you Mr chair this um this will not
affect any have any impact at all on um
town to um town to toown um inter
Municipal agreements which is the intent
of the original Bill between London
Dairy and dairy and so if if C Brook is
a town um and I'm Hampton I forget what
the other town is in town as well this
would have no impact at all if either of
those were cities then this amendment
would um would have an impact but I'd
like to just make one other statement um
in response to uh representative harb's
comment um just for clarification this
is um this amendment will while it will
enable you know intermunicipal
agreements between cities will also
allow intermunicipal
agreements between a city and between a
town and a city that's that's the case
that's the majority case um NASA for
example is surrounded by towns there are
no other cities um I don't think
Hudson's the city um there are no other
cities
around it um and so the uh the intent is
to allow for example Hollis or marac to
um to share uh septic system uh
wastewater treatment plant uh facilities
if needed and let ntion would benefit
from that the same way that Dairy would
benefit um from this proposed
Bill see no other questions or no other
comments on the amend
please call the
rooll on the amendment
H watch pass Representative harb
no representative GS no what I said
representative Horgan
no uh clerk votes no representative con
no representative wolf
no represent Miku no representative
Donnelly no representative Dunn
no representative Vale
no representative wrong
yes representative Kelly
yes representative Simpson
yes representative Baldwin
yes representative Derby yes
correct oh um representative ho
yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Ryan
Yes uh the
chair call Representative Vil again I
think call Representative Vil again
representative Vil your vote Yes
is yes so I'm going to put you here and
my my vote is no your vote is no so your
number 10 10 to 10 10 to 10 10 to 10 the
10 to 10 the uh motion fails
uh on the on the amendment on the motion
of ought to
pass wish
to speak on your motion V to pass or
should we just go right to
vot thank you Mr chairman I think it's a
a useful Bill uh an important bill for
economic development it will benefit
large parts of the state we've had a
fair amount of testimony a fair amount
of discussion and I urge the committee
to support the bill as introduced on the
on the bill ought to pass cler please
call the all yes representative harb yes
representative WS representative Horgan
yes CL votes yes representative KH yes
representative wolf
yes representative mik yes
representative Donell yes representative
dun yes representative Veil yes
representative Rong yes representative
Kelly yes representative zimson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative Derby
no representative ho
yes representative lontine yes
representative lit yes representative
Brian yes and the
chair yes that's 19 to one motion passes
19 to
one who
sent pardon you can put it on the
consent calendar but I'm going to write
a Minority Report
otpa uh you can't on on the consent
calendar okay so then I'll let's just
let it go to a Voice vote on the floor I
want to write an OTP motion OTP
report okay would you you you you w't go
to if it's on the consent calendar no
I'm sorry but I meant what I meant to
say is let's keep put it on the regular
calendar regular calendar and I'll just
let it go to a Voice vote on the floor
write to minority yes
okay okay so it is not on not on
consent okay and F that's that's it
we're uh
that's final I'll close the hearing then
the uh executive session and we'll open
right up
with
pardon okay I'm just get started
on
people well they just going to
the little I think there
e
sorry my scribble is it's so
illegible you know who I
am thank you Mr chairman uh my name is
Keith Murphy I'm the state senator for
District 16 the towns of gtown hooks at
Candy Raymond and uh the first ward in
Manchester uh this bill should look very
very familiar because it was word for
word identical to House Bill 1429 which
you heard in I believe passed I think
unanimously um brought the bill forward
because uh Hadley Falls Dam in center of
gtown was there for 100 years it was
used to generate electricity uh it lost
the license with firk was no longer
economically viable and DS has moved to
remove it and it's going to be gone this
year um this raised the question of how
many dams do we have like that well
there's 27 three state-owned
dams the code the cost to bring them up
to current standard would be$ 414
million dollar 63 of those 273 dams have
been designated by Dees as high
Hazard the um the issue is that these
dams Beyond
providing uh a natural resource for our
citizens is also a huge source of
property value for our citizens
if those dams any of those dams that go
away the property value is adjacent are
going to fall precipitously for
waterfront properties over half in
general over half of the value of those
properties is tied to the fact that it's
Waterfront
so this is a a property tax issue as
much as a natural resource
issue
um Dees has made the decision at least
in some cases that it's simply not worth
the cost to repair them and they don't
want the continual cost of maintaining
them and they don't want the liability
in having those dams remain and so in
some cases after a very thorough process
I give the department credit but after a
very thorough process of evaluation
they've decided to remove those
dams so Hadley's only the first in G
toown but every one of us in this room
has towns or is close to towns
that is going to face this issue and so
it seemed to me that it was important to
come up with a process to address the
issue and so the bill as passed through
the Senate does two things one it
creates a general obligation for the
Department to at least offer the town uh
the the right to have the
dam uh take over the liability and the
cost of Maintenance and secondly it
creates a revolving Loan Fund um to uh
allow communities to tap into
resources uh to bring those dams up to
code should they choose to accept the
responsibility after this committee
passed House Bill 1429 it was sent to
Ways and Means um ways and means if you
listen to the
hearing in my opinion they really
focused on the policy question you I
once sat on house waying means believe
it or not my first term
I thought we were supposed to focus on
dollars and cents but they really did
focus on the policy question and they
ited House Bill
1429 and I have no wish to see this bill
which I think is a very good
idea uh face the same outcome and so the
amendment that I'm waiting for any
moment strips out the second part of the
bill the section two dealing with the
Loan Fund which I assume was the trigger
that sent it to Ways and Means
the amendment also makes a small
correction uh to address an issue that
was brought forward by Dees two days ago
in a letter um
which includes the easement any easement
associated with the dam would also be
able to be transferred to the town so I
think that addresses their concern there
was a question of whether the the the
bill includes language um dealing with
DS's right to take away dams if they're
deemed to be environmentalist
um unwise and I did include that
language on page one line 21 and
22 so I truly hope that when the
amendment comes in should the committee
choose to adopt it uh and save it from
the same outcome as House Bill
1429 uh I hope you'll look kindly upon
it and I'm happy to answer any questions
okay representative L montin followed by
representative
Derby thank you Mr chair um
with the and thank you for taking my
question with the if you're removing
section two in your
Amendment um but section three which for
me was important that we included that
in um hb1 1429 but I wasn't able to get
the amendment um written the way that
would work but um if you're removing
section two the procedure um
um uh to exempt that if there's a
compelling environmental interest refers
to section two so it's still in there if
you Che
out section two well section two and
really three and four they all deal with
the revolving Loan Fund so they would
all have to go in order to I think pass
Ways and Means muster but if you look at
line assuming we're looking at the same
bill here um lines 21 and 22 unless
there is a compelling environmental
interest in
removal
right um oh it does refer to paragraph
2 um yeah which is above it
so okay like for me can I answer your
question ma'am I just want to be sure
that that line is kept in there if you
remove section
two yes uh section two is it won't touch
it yes ma'am next question
is representative Derby thank you Mr
chair thank you senator for taking my
question yes sir um the bill that we
passed was an amended bill um that
introduced the new um Loan Fund at least
that's my recollection and I sorry that
I'm not completely prepared I I didn't
know an amendment was coming um the
original bill was to um add the purpose
to the existing Dam uh add a new purpose
to the dam maintenance fund and there
was um my recollection and my note say
that there was some strong concern about
that because of the funding sources for
that um and that it wouldn't be able to
provide a uh it wouldn't be able to
provide these loans that were desired
under you know under section one so what
um if we remove the dedicated fund what
where do you propos to the money comes
from that's a great question I agree
that the revolving loan fund is an
important piece of the original bill um
that's why I included it in the in the
original bill as drafted having said
that uh if Ways and Means does not going
to allow that fund to come into being
and that's what they've indicated
through killing the companion bill it's
better to still have in my opinion the
obligation of Dees to at least offer the
community the right to the dam and the
easement and the town can decide whether
they want to adopt that and take on the
cost themselves it would also leave in
place um on page one lines 23 to 26 it
leaves in place the Department's
obligation to offer documentation
regarding Dam's condition and a good
faith estimate of cost of repairs so DS
would still have to go to the community
and say this Dam uh isn't going to meet
code it requires in the case of Hadley
Falls it was $5 million I believe it's
going to require $5 million in cost um
you can choose to take it or
not now without Al loone f the truth is
is that very few communities I think in
general are going to take that and I
would look to come back next year uh
assuming that we're all lucky enough to
be sitting in in this building and to um
establish a Loan Fund with perhaps a
Ways and Means Committee that might
smile upon it for for a followup and
then thank you Mr chair very briefly so
just just to make sure I I understand so
you're suggesting let the um let the U
municipalities figure out how they're
going to pay for it there would be no um
there would be no change to existing
other existing funds to provide some
other loan
mechanism that's correct I me it is a
non-budget year and I think that may
have been part of the concern part ways
and means it it is better to have the
obligation of Dees I think made into law
to offer the dam at least have them have
the ability to to um to choose to take
on the expense and the liability if they
so choose I know in the case of of of
gtown they felt like they had some
notice but they really didn't see what
options they had and you know the having
a an empowerment in the middle of their
town really they identified with that
they it had been there for Generations
they really felt strongly about keeping
it they really didn't have any any
chance to save
it at least that was their feeling okay
representative Khan for a
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you senator for taking my question yes
sir uh
we talking about two uh different kind
of uh expense that uh is going to be
imposed on the town and cities one is to
bring it to the code and the other is
the
maintenance
so how many how many dams are not uh
fall into the code right now that uh out
of 200 some dams in New Hampshire many
are not
um is falling to the
code my notes indicate that there's 273
dams that are owned by the state of the
273 the state handles maintenance on 208
of them I'm unaware of how many do not
meet code to the letter but 63 of them
have have been designated as quote high
Hazard dams
unquote um you
know dams are expensive to to correct
and maintain it doesn't help that as
well that the the standards have
certainly increased over time Hadley
Falls Dam if you have ever been there
isn't very large and um to bring it to
code they essentially have to remove it
and reinstall it tying into Bedrock on
both sides of the river which that's
where the expense is followup Mr
chairman for
followup um if we talk about 208 that
state maintains right now and if those
208 is not code and we imposing those uh
to the towns and cities uh small towns
it will be it could be a very big
expense for their uh budget and
everything so that is a concern for this
members I I think you misunderstood my
my statement I'm not saying that 208
dams don't meet code I'm saying I don't
know how many meet code or do not I only
know that 63 of them are high hazard out
of the 208 dams some some number of them
would meet current standards some number
do
not this bill does not obligate
communities to take on the liability it
simply allows them to take on liability
if they choose it's enabling legislation
thank
you representative har thank you Mr
chair thank you senator for taking this
question I think representative L
montain asked the question but I can't
remember that you actually addressed it
uh you mentioned that we will be getting
or you will be getting um an amendment
to delete section two
correct but I look at the bill in
section three and four relates to
section two so is your Amendment going
to delete two three and four I believe
in my answer representative L mon I did
indicate that sections two three and
four all deal with the revolving Loan
Fund and they would all be stripped by
the amendment I just want to make sure
the others were covered the important
language to represent L montain was was
contained uh in section so it would not
be touched thank
you representative wrong thank thank you
Mr chair thank you senator for taking my
question' so as I understand the bill as
you're proposing it be amended dams
regardless of whether they've been
deemed a menace or non- Menace can be
transferred to the town if the town
wants that Dam correct and then they
would then be responsible for raising
the funds within the tax
to maintain or repair the
dam but I'm wondering about a scenario
where if the town has to raise those
funds it may have to be through a bond
issue or a very large budget hit if that
fails and the dam then doesn't have the
the you know the town doesn't have the
money to make the repairs and if that
Dam should fail and impact communities
Downstream would that town then be
liable for any damages um how would
because we're not just talking we're
talking about the liability of the dam
but that you're with this bill the town
is also taking on a liability that may
impact many could be many communities
Downstream I was just wondering if
there's any recourse for the town if
that happens because the state would
then be totally out of it then
correct oh that's a very complicated
question with a number of ways to answer
it first off the line uh 20 and 21 says
uh unless the commissioner of
Environmental Services believes the dam
to be an imminent danger of failure and
a threat to the lives and property
Downstream so DS is already already
empowered to remove a dam that they find
in in in need of in danger of failure um
but dams are subject to routine
inspection anything that has a firk
license has a very very thorough
inspection process
um and again this does not obligate
towns to take on a dam it simply says
that prior to
removal so DS would have already had to
decide this Dam's going to go
away it only applies to dams that DS has
said we're going to take this Dam away
now instead of just taking it away they
have to say unless you want
it and you can decide whether you want
the expense or
not and the bill also if a few recall it
expanded the time so that the towns
would have a chance to be able to go
through a process to try to get the the
funding that I think was part of the
amendment process that we had which was
incorporated into this
bill
uh and uh was very similar to what uh I
think this bill was put together because
of I guess because it ran into the
problems in ways and means that that's
correct okay and so we're trying
to basically be a workaround uh I let me
let me two things the our um committee
researchers is trying to track down the
state of the uh of the amendment uh it
it uh it will have to come in under the
house name so I should put my name on it
so just to able to get it through
because otherwise if you came in on the
your name it wouldn't it wouldn't count
I understand
so and uh thirdly I I've served on Ways
and Means yesterday as
substitute and this is that issue came
up about what further bills they had and
the chair said well none I said wait a
minute uh you have one in
resources and what one is that oh that's
the that's the B the the uh the dam Bill
and they
going and put it this way the
question I had several
people said please remove the part
around uh around funding so that we
don't get it so I think they understand
the issue that they they now I don't
want to say anything on the record but
uh I think they would be they would
rather they we remove the the the
funding for this time for for this point
in time and be able to to take up the
funding next year under the normal
course of action of course that and Mr
chairman if I may you did exec exec a
bill and you voted it all to pass that I
think May provide some additional
opportunities for revenue and ways to
fund those repairs so maybe it's better
that we wait till next year on that
piece and just focus on creating the
obligation of the department to offer
the dam
okay with that is there any other
questions
that a question of the chair are is this
a bill that we have to have an executive
session on today yes we do okay thank
you
yes this bill it has to go
out a bit of
um thank you Mr CH I did have one more
question sorry for the delay um one of
the changes between um this bill and the
bill that um the amendment that we
passed is a particular uh um sort of
qualification about the with it's on
line 14 um sorry 15 but it's it's
combined with line 14 it has to do with
if the municipality doesn't ex um
decides not to um you know uh buy the
dam for one reason or another um the DS
will offer it to land Owners Association
of land owners or interested parties the
change is that it says capable of
assessing local property taxes that
stuck out as me is uh because I wasn't
it's not clear to me what associations
can assess local property
taxes thank you for the question
representative this was a a change that
was requested in uh the Senate um
committee your counterparts across the
wall um H requested by the principal
Association
um and
I I'm not sure that there are any public
entities U that aren't municipalities
capable of assessing property taxes
although you do have some things like
Pilots um there are groups that are able
through basically communities are able
to delegate taxing authority to those uh
to those groups but there are there are
certainly groups registered public
entities capable of of issuing debt so I
think that that's why I let let that go
thanks for the background there yes
sir representative R for addition
question thank you Mr chair so the
action we have to take today is
predicated on getting an amendment which
we haven't received yet that's so I mean
we're not going to sit here and wait
what I will do after the
is uh I will not I will
recess the meeting or and then start you
know the additional hearings that we we
have have and when the amendment comes
in uh I'll I will then re I will
then uh re re re recall reopen the
meeting and uh in order to actually take
the the the vote uh otherwise we're just
going to be sitting
here your time is too valuable for
representative just question of the
chair Mr chairman we have a hearing at
12 12:00 that's potentially a like
fairly well attended hearing right on uh
the boat voting Bill yes so we could
potentially recess until after that and
have
until 130 I will I will recess that
meeting when as soon as the amendment
comes in I will re I will re recess that
meeting for you know 15 20 minutes and I
will
reconvene this
meeting to take care of the bill to pass
what has to hopefully the amendment
doesn't have any pickups in it then then
it gets to be a real problem so we have
a few hours I
think but uh we'll get uh we'll we will
then work the we will then take care of
that and
then get
a adjourn this this meeting then
and reconvene the other meeting I I'll
go stand by LS and wait for
it yes go stand over them and
say and and just say y gez your budget's
getting smaller every year we would
never do that Mr chair
yeah yeah you and me
both thank thank you thank you I'm going
to recess this meeting for uh anyone
else to testify is there anyone else who
is there anyone else here to testify on
this by the way you want you want to
testify or or you want to just get
out okay
question yeah there was a rep Tom Dolan
but uh he said he was testimony but I
don't see him here that's for the next
oh oh that's for the next one yeah
that's 431 okay that's that's for the
final bill yeah what do you want to
oh you have written test all right
good 5:39 morning Mr ch39 yes for the
record rainy pet here I'm the Water
Division director at Dees and here as
you will see in our letter of testimony
we support this bill um we have worked
with Senator Murphy I think and S
Senator delisandros Bill which you
passed earlier today 541 to look at
Revenue sour es I mean it all comes into
play I think the big thing that we have
concerns with is always funding um and I
think Senator Murphy's amendment makes a
lot of sense that we step back and walk
before we run on a loan program as you
know we have many loan programs for
water and wastewater one of the concerns
about the Loan program for this Dam
program is funding and number two as
Senator Murphy noted we figure we have
some somewhere north of $414 million
doll needed just to bring the 273 dams
we have up to our current standards Dam
standards so I think I have nothing to
add over Senator Murphy's uh quite
articulate explanation of the bill but
I'm certainly here to answer any
questions of Dees that you may
need any more any questions from uh
chair
representative thank you Mr shair and
thanks for taking my question
um is there already a process say um if
there if this were to pass would
Dees
review do a new review perhaps before
they agree to pass it on to determine
the current safety of the dam and to
assess the environmental impact of the
dam staying or or not staying would
would it automatically be reviewed again
yes good question thank you yeah the
bill actually provides a year where Dees
will notify the town or the municipality
if you will and also provide information
about the cost and and what kind of
condition the dam is in in it relative
to public health and safety so that is
part of the bill is
written representative wolf thank you Mr
chairman thank
you can never remember your title R
thank you for taking my question um if
there is an error in the state's
estimate of costs or things like that
underlying conditions that were not
mentioned does the state assume any
responsibility because of
that uh good question considering I'm a
civil engineer and not an attorney I'm
not sure I can answer that but I I would
feel very comfortable about the
analytics that we do when we look at
dams and what's needed we go all the way
from the hydrogeological analysis and
look at what the Bedrock is is it on
Stone is it on Sand so if that would
have occurred and we didn't make a
mistake then I suspect you know if it
went to court it would be decided there
but I have all the confidence in the
world that the technical expertise that
we possess I don't see that as a
potential
risk thank you very much um just point
clarification it says in the letter um
the 63 dams class 63 dams are classified
as high Hazard the failure of any of
which would cause loss of life so high
Hazard
means when you put a dam into the high
Hazard category that is simply to
categorize them as sort of proximity to
population or does it also entail um
the condition of the damp thanks yeah
when we rate something as high Hazard
that means there's a possibility of loss
of life um public infrastructure
driveways those types of things and
that's when it gets into that high
Hazard status we currently have 63 High
Hazard dams um that need to be addressed
over time and we've estimated somewhere
around 300 million to take care of just
the dams that stay owns we do regulate
keep in mind some 2600 dams throughout
the state 273 of those are owned by Dees
and they were formally owned by fishing
game in some cases so funding for this
program is a big issue that's why it's
kind of exciting that 549 was voted off
the pass today to figure out how we can
fund these projects you know I've been a
Dees for go 50 years now and I think um
when I look back on when the state took
over dams it was well be before my
tenure there but I think over the years
the politics approved taking over a lot
of these dams and there was a lot of
risk associated with the repair keep in
mind most of these dams are 50 years old
some are 100 years old and they've had
little attention over the years this
year let's say to do damn maintenance on
what we consider the highest PR priority
dams we've got a capital budget request
in for 17 million um and that's where
the funding comes from now in the the
bill that Senator Murphy is doing an
amendment on I think
4558 that's the dam maintenance fund
which used to be a little more flush
with money when the hydro people were
paying into it right now their return
their rate of return is very low we have
a lot of people that are opting out of
their F license to have Hydro power
so the need for funding to repair these
has been exacerbated over time and
that's why I think 541 is such an
important
bill is there any other questions if not
we assess the thank you very much thank
you I will recess the hearing we uh
you're seeing an amendment that came in
there is an issue with it uh it's being
taken care of so we'll recess and uh
start the hearing on the next uh the
next
bill representative Arby thank you Mr
chair question this a question for you
with respect to the amendment you said
there was an issue can you yes can you
mention that issue uh it's right it's
the last page on the amendment you'll
see in the bottom it's uh it's it's
talks about providing funds for loans
transfer the dams thank you I just
wanted to make sure that that I that's
the one y okay thank you okay yeah that
otherwise what we're doing the amendment
would not would not have done the job so
I will uh I will recess the hearing on
uh Senate Bill
539 and open the hearing on Senate Bill
5 47 relative to certain
requirements relative to certain
requirements relative to cell chip
programs somebody's relatives are really
good
any and this is good morning morning so
there's testimony coming around to you
did I get a is our pin card oh oh yeah
and I'm holding the one that you're
holding not a
souvenir goad thank you Mr chair and
honorable members for the record my name
is Deborah alcher I am the senator from
District 24 and I am here today to
introduce Senate Bill 547
um which actually is a companion bill to
Senate Bill 546 that was heard yesterday
in a different committee but all right
it's all good um the land and Community
Heritage investment program otherwise
known as elip has invested $58 million
through 546 grants in 98 New Hampshire
communities I'm sure everybody here
knows of one of the projects thanks to
the work of this program that preserves
and protects our past so that future
future Granite Staters will be able to
connect to our rich and storied Origins
as we evolve into the future 170
historic structures have been
rehabilitated and
237,000 acres of land in New Hampshire
have been
conserved as with any program evolution
is necessary and the bill before you
Senate Bill 5 47 is an effort to ensure
the grant funded programs have
enforcement Fidelity that accurately
reflect to the processes under which the
El chip program functions I am very
pleased to bring Senate Bill 547 to you
with the wind at its back having come
out of the senate committee with
unanimous recommendation of ought to
pass and passage on the Senate consent
calendar while I am thrilled to have had
the experience of serving on the board
of directors
with chairman Ren
Zulo for the past year and a half the
details of Grant applications Awards and
management are still relatively new to
me so I am equally as thrilled to have
El Chip's executive director Paula
Belmore here with me today to provide
the precise answers to questions you may
have about the proposed changes to RSA
227 DM semicolon 2 in Senate Bill 547
and I thank you for time and
attention so I'm going to turn it over
to Paula because I put 90 seconds on my
card and I think I I think I nailed it
yeah and and Paula did you pill out fill
out a pen card can you do one after your
speak sure thank you they like to keep
records
thanks I'm here I'm happy to answer any
questions of the
committee you have any questions of
either of the speakers
representative Darby thank you thank you
Mr chair um my first question um maybe
let me not say it that way my question
is
um paragraph or uh definition for
introduces a term called a historic
preservation project it says or uh Farm
viability program interestingly uh Farm
viability program is defined further
down but I searched and searched last
night for historic preservation project
and maybe it's obvious but I can't find
the definition and there does seem to be
various terms with respect to Historic
and preservation in different as areas
of this
statute thank you for the question
you're correct there is not a definition
for historic preservation project
proposed or included in the statute as
it currently stands um I could look
through the existing statute and show
you where um elip is authorized to fund
Rehabilitation of his hisor buildings
and structures and that's what we're
referring to there um and I'm not sure
if that sufficiently addresses your
concern I believe it would be in section
one of 227 M follow up thank you Mr
chair I I did see that
actually um my I'm a bit pantic about um
you know I guess you'd call me a policy
uh geek or whatever but um if that's the
intent is there any would be be
opposition to defining that term no in
statute so that just so that's clear
what what the intent is okay thank you
very
much any other questions representative
wolf thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um you've
stricken out and it's hard to read
through this in an asked question but uh
you struck out the uh word in
line 10 I believe it is term
easements you explain why you've
stricken that
out easement interests in as used in the
statute refer to Perpetual easements um
and so where in this particular section
we're talking about easements that will
stand over time in perpetuity and the
term easement wouldn't necessarily apply
in that case so in order to understand
that we would look through the rest of
the statute for other instances where
the term easement interest is applied
and that always is for easements that
are
Perpetual follow
up thank you so does this mean that El
chip will no longer Grant term
easements uh no it means that when we
are referring to easement interest so
for example certain obligations of a
grant or certain legal requirements
would apply to an easement that is per
ual that may not apply to a term
easement so we would still be able to
fund term easements thank
you any other
questions the second time representative
Darby thank you Mr chair um
I
um you state you I read the commentary
the email that was sent as well so I
tried to do some background here but I I
couldn't quite track it you it mentioned
removing the um the need for a qualif
qualifying stewardship plan as part of
the uh I'm sorry part application but it
was still required I was hoping you
could just tell me where it's where in
statute it's still required as part of
the approval um thank you for the
question it is not still required in
statute the statute now clarifies that
the applicant must demonstrate their
capacity demonstrating stewardship
capacity can be done in a number of ways
first and foremost for land conservation
through accreditation with the national
land trust Alliance but also through
past history we request copies of their
policies procedures things of that
nature um the change is that we don't
require that
demonstration through an actual plan
created for a specific property before
they actually receive the
fund and then our program what our
program rules with a lowercase are um do
require that steward Plan before they
receive their final
Grant thank thank thank
you anyone else before representative
Darby goes for the third
time representative Darby you got the
floor oh no representa
wol representative wolf for the second
time then representative D thank you um
you now have the commission of the
Department of Business and economic
Affairs
being named in here as opposed to
somebody else it used to be the office
of planning is there some reason that
you went to the office of business
because I consider that
more a department that is trying to
generate funds and bring more people to
New Hampshire as opposed to natural and
cultural resources which I would think
would be I I do understand your question
although we didn't make the decision the
decision was made when the office of
State planning was dissolved that seat
moved to Bea um however the design from
Bea is the director of the office of
outdoor recreation development so there
is there is a tie there um but that was
a decision made I Believe by the
governor's office when that office was
dis when State planning was dissolved
there were a number of Statute changes
this one just seems to have
slipped under the radar and wasn't made
at that time there's a lot of them here
yeah representative Darby thank you Mr
chair this is my final question um the
there's a change with respect to um what
it can fund um it it quotes another
section of statue and it was you know C
through F and it changed through a
through g g in the in the testimony that
was received or in the email that was
received I thought it said that there's
no change in what it was able to fund
but the the bill I didn't understand
that statement with respect to the
expansion of the you know the sub
paragraphs absolutely thank you for the
question I'd have to go back and look at
the a through G I'm not sure if the C
reference originally was a mistake I do
have a copy of the full statute I could
look that up but the expansion of one
bullet point is moving a contribution to
a stewardship fund from a later
paragraph of the statute and including
it in the list of eligible expenses it
was an eligible expense but it was
referenced later and only as a non-ash
expense which as we know when um an
organization is fundraising for a
project they are raising cash to put
into an endowment for stewardship so it
there was a disconnect in the statute as
previously
written and I can look I do have a copy
of the FB I can look and see what the C
to a is
I just um from your perspective you
wouldn't be increasing what um El would
be pay be paying for if the intent is to
is to keep the the you know the the
funds available for the same purposes
that's absolutely correct we are trying
to Simply clarify it so when the
potential applicant reads the list see
the entire list okay thank you maybe
maybe when I ask you about some language
for my other amendment I can ask about
that Clause as well Absolut thank
you anyone else have any questions
before we go back to representative wolf
I don't see any new
hands representative wolf thank you for
taking the question on uh bottom of page
two you've uh restricted out appraise
market value of the
property
um and put in a a percentage of the
funds that were required for the project
now
if a gift of a historic resource is
presented and there's
no you can't use that for um
funding is that what you're saying this
is a it's a seemingly easy question with
a very complicated answer but I will do
my best the full fair market value of a
project of a property being acquired is
eligible however if the purchase price
is less than that amount the donated
value is considered a non-cash
contribution to the project so the total
cost of the project remains $100 but if
$10 in property value were being being
donated we consider that a contribution
from another source to the project so we
won't we will not um reimburse for that
donated value but the total project
value Remains the full fair market value
and I'd be happy to meet with you uh and
go through it I I it's incredibly
complicated and that change intends to
simplify exactly what you just pointed
out so that applicants can understand
what's included
any other questions for our
speakers don't see
anyone you have your mic
on I guess no more questions thank you
very much for your testimony and if I
can remind you if you can fill out a
pink card thank you is there anyone else
to speak on SB 547 SB
547 I'll ask one more time anyone else
is speak on SB
547 who you
ask no
I we're waiting a moment before we call
the next hearing I thank all the people
that I'm sure are here for the wake
surfing uh we're trying to decide about
possibly exacting the bill we just
heard let me just ask representative har
perhaps we could find out if people are
feeling pretty much unanimously that we
can exec this will we take an informal
poll here as as those of you here but
the public may not know um although it's
not on for exing if the minority and
majority leaders say let's exact we can
exact this bill but we don't want to cut
anyone off for anything that they may
wish to do so does anyone have an
objection to executing this
bill
547 representative Darby yeah we're
talking about the El bill right yes yeah
one we just heard right I I think that
that one term needs to be CL needs to be
added like I like I suggested and I'd
like I want to get a clarification
on um section
three okay guess we
won't so in deference to representative
Derby we won't EXA this bill so we'll
probably be coming back I don't I
haven't scheduled next week but we'll
come back for this it's not an early
bill but we need to get it done um so if
there's no one else to testify on SB 547
I'll close the
hearing and I think we're still waiting
for the amendment on 539 to correct the
amendment that we got so we'll continue
since we have uh people to speak in
regards to SB 431 I'll open the hearing
on SB 431 relative to wake surfing
thank you Mr Vice chairman uh thank you
members of the house uh resource
recreational and development committee I
don't think I've ever been in front of
this committee before in my seven eight
years in the house in the legislature
now uh so for the record I'm Senator Tim
Lang I'm the state senator from District
2 I'm the prime sponsor of SP 431 and I
appreciate the bipartisan Senate and
House members who have helped me
co-sponsor this bill um the Senate
passed this bill on a
bipartisan um Voice vote this bill seeks
to address an issue that's come before
the legislature time and time again in
the past as it relates to the very
popular family water sport wake surfing
the sport has been around for more than
a decade and it's popular among
recreational boating families in New
Hampshire some Shore phone owners have
sought to restrict or outright ban the
sport of wake surfing because they are
concerned about possible erosion on a
shoreline so what does this bill do why
are we here this bill is a compromise
Bill we were trying to reach a
reasonable measure recognizing the uh
science around shoreline erosion at the
same time not looking to do a ban
because that's not the New Hampshire way
uh so trying to find a reasonable
compromise what this bill does is it
establishes a 200 foot setback for the
people uh participating in wake surfing
um its best practices and scientific
Studies have shown that a 200 foot
setback is appropriate and minimally
restrictive it is fur it it further
pushes back from current boting for
regular boting which is 150 F feet so it
adds 50 ft um the second provision of
the bill is it it it requires an
education component on the on the behalf
of the Marine Patrol the department of
safety to um include the ability for
Wake server uh for boers to push the
that can push the Wake the surf wake to
away into the center of the lake versus
the edge of the shore and the department
said they have the ability to include
this information one of the other things
it does is it limits um the boting
activity to only Lakes over um 50 acres
so as I don't have to tell your
committee public Body Waters over 10
acres are held in the public trust by
the state um for all people in the state
um to enjoy it's our duty protect all
that a the public access as well as both
the environmental and econ economy that
are important in Hampshire Senate Bill
431 seeks that a greater buffer not a
ban on wake surfing
there are a lot of people behind me I'm
sure you've got a few dozen cards back
there so I will take questions but
understand depending on what your
questions are there may be way more
smarter people behind me to answer very
particular questions so I thank you for
taking my testimony again um I I I'm
hoping to put this issue to bed uh so we
don't have to keep having the same bill
come in over and over again in different
forms
so I'm still reaching for your card
sorry it I said
remember to do on well after three terms
in the house you would think but more
and more times I forget in than Senator
any questions for the senator
representative
McHugh thank you Mr chairman thank you
Senator thanks for bring Tim hello yeah
fellow Tim nice to see you thanks for
bringing this bill um did the Senate
committee consider the impact or
considering like 300 feet or any 300
foot restriction instead of 200 or any
depth restrictions in the process
absolutely thank you for the question so
again we did look at lots of options uh
the outright ban 500t 300 ft again this
this bill this U because we amended it
um from the original how I originally
put it in and so we we did things like
50 acres or larger right so one of the
things you have to think about while
you're discussing this is that as you
restrict from the lake Edge you're
narrowing the channel That all these
boats are going to be acting in so you
Inc you almost decrease safety right so
it's one of the reasons why if you go
too far in you're going to create a very
narrow channel where the uh the sport is
able to do and then you're going to just
increase the density of the boats in
that area which reduces the safety so
taking all of that into consideration
the 200 foot uh seemed to be the most uh
place where we found consensus again it
was a bipartisan vote in the Senate to
pass this bill I believe it was four to
one out of the committee uh bipartisan
so thank
you represent Rong yeah thank you Mr
chair and thank you senator for taking
my question you mentioned in your
remarks that the 200 ft was based on
several scientific studies or you you
plural do do you know what studies those
are I did read them I don't remember off
the top that who was the ones that did
the study but I'm sure there are people
behind me that can answer that question
for you but I did read the study there
was one that was presented to me and we
looked at and and had the 200 ft we also
looked at the 500 foot again we go back
to you're balancing not only the erosion
but the safety aspect and so the 200t is
where we found that we we allow for both
taking into account reducing the
shoreline erosion but at the same time
not creating a safety Problem by
narrowing the the field too much okay
followup Mr follow up so um when you
were reviewing the studies there was
just one for 200 or were there multiple
no I read actually I read two and I also
but I also read a 300 and I think I read
a 500 as well so I read multiple B
multiple studies um and but how we got
the 200 200 was everybody looking at all
of them and deciding this was the
appropriate action okay thank you
representative Derby thank you thank you
Mr chair thank you senator for taking my
question um as I understand it you are
represent the Lakes Region as well
correct and so I'm wondering if you have
received any um any concerns about um
erosion or water quality um related to
wake surfing from your constituents
thank you for your question so yes i' i'
I've heard from both sides in The Lakes
Region there are people very much in
support of this bill and there are
people people who don't want us to touch
it at all just leave it the way it is
and there are people that just want an
outright band so I've heard from all
spectrums uh relative to this bill as
the prime sponsor um again I think this
bill was a compromise bill it's a way to
recognize the shore erosion take some
action to protect as our duty of of here
in the state is to protect our
Waterfront but not make it so
restrictive that we impinge upon people
who are trying to enjoy the lake as
well anyone else to have a question for
the senator
excellent thank you Senator thanks
guys so as my chair always says we're
going to alternate between those opposed
and those in favor um speaking in
opposition Harry
vog good afternoon uh Mr chair and
members of the committee for the record
my name is har Vogel I am the senior
biologist and executive director of the
lon preservation committee uh I thank
you for the opportunity to voice lpc's
opposition to Senate Bill 431 which
would set what evidence clearly
demonstrates are inadequate limits on
wake surfing on New Hampshire
Waters LPC Works to protect and restore
a healthy loon population in New
Hampshire through monitoring management
research and education with respect to
potential impacts to loons we emphasize
the following reasons that we oppose
cill
431 the first is that Lon Nest can be
destroyed by wave of action loons are
adapted to swimming and Diving and
rather than walking they move with
difficulty on land and therefore they
always Nest right at the water's edge
waves from boat wakes can wash over loon
nests causing them to fail in some cases
nesting is when loons are most
vulnerable and over 40% of New Hampshire
Lun nests fail from various causes
despite our best efforts to protect them
intensive management of nest sites has
been needed to continue the hard one and
ongoing recovery of loons which remain a
threatened species uh in the
state we disagree with the 200 foot
standard proposed in Senate Bill 431
because it is not supported by any
reputable study the primary study that
recommended that standard which was
funded by the national Marine
manufacturers Association was based on
computer models that the authors
themselves stated are not accurate at
distances of more than three boat
lengths and of no value at more than 100
ft from the boat their unsubstantiated
recommendation for the 200t standard is
an outlier among other wake surfing
studies which recommend minimum
protective zones of up to a th000 feet
or more wake surfing studies that use
actual field measurements site wave
heights and wave energy that are
significantly greater than other forms
of boating so for example water
environmental Consultants found that
wake surfing produced a greater than 7in
high wave at 500 ft distance and a
49% increase in wave energy compared to
a cruising boat a wave of this height
and power would easily swamp many luness
in New Hampshire which are typically
less than 6 Ines above the water
line in the Senate testimony for this
bill I heard lobbyist say that loons are
doing fine in New Hampshire and the real
problem for loons is lead fishing lead
fishing tackle and I agree that lead
tackle continues to kill loons in New
Hampshire we've already lost one from
tackle this year but loons are facing
many threats not just one and wake
sports are impacting the recovery of
this threatened and much loved species
we experienced no growth in Lon paars
last year and we had a record number of
Nest failures including a record number
of failures from flooded nests a 200
foot no wake Sport Zone represents only
a token increase in the existing New
Hampshire no wake zone and that
historical standard was created over 60
years ago long before there was wake
surfing on new Hampshire Lakes wake
boats and wake surfing are by Design
categorically different than the
recreational boating that prompted our
original no wake regulations the
proposed 200 foot distance is not nearly
enough to protect lons from those much
higher and more powerful
waves we're also concerned about
shoreline erosion and water quality
loons are visual hunters and they need
clean clear water to catch fish the
potential for wake surfing to increase
shoreline erosion and turbidity of our
Lakes Means A reduced ability of bons
and other Aquatic species to find Nest
sites and food New Hampshire's 150t no
zone is provided an important buffer to
protect our shorelines from erosion
today a much more significant buffer is
needed to guard against a significantly
bigger and more energetic waves created
by wake surfing we support efforts to
provide those needed protections for
lakes and loons and we oppose the
inadequate standard proposed in Senate
Bill 431 thank you for considering LS
and other wildlife in your contemplation
of this Bill and thank you for your
consideration of any amendments that
would protect our loons other Wildlife
shorelines and water quality in New
Hampshire that is the end of my
testimony I do have written testimony um
to distribute um from both Lon
preservation committee and New Hampshire
aabon and I sit on the Environmental
Policy Committee of New Hampshire
audabon um and I would be happy to
answer any questions
May any questions for Mr vog
representative rang and representative
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr B
for taking my question yes I actually
have two one um you've talked about the
danger to loons even with it with 200
for their nesting yes um and you've
talked about the turbidity of um you
know the water that's created from like
you know the erosion and loons being
unable to look for food um are there any
dangers to loons if uh with wake boats
just like being in the middle like even
you know more than 300 ft from Shore or
any of those dangers that you've talked
about would they still exist 300 feet
from Shore yes thank thank you for the
question so um my understanding is that
wake boats in the in the action of wake
surfing are actually moving fairly
slowly that's one of the things that
allows them to create these tremendous
waves um and and so while we lose loons
every year from collisions with
motorboats and and jet skis I would
expect that there will probably be less
of a danger from a wake booat you know
moving at that slow speed than from from
a motorboat speeding along the surface
of of the water there's been some
suggestion that these huge wakes can
actually separate you know loon chicks
from adults and the process of of
feeding and cause of separation of
family um I think that there might be
some truth to that but I'm not sure that
we have good data okay thank you
sentive Hoy thank you for taking my
question uh have you uh discussed
anything relative to the depth of the
water that wake boats are being used
in uh yes thank you for the for the
question and and again my understanding
from previous testimony is that in order
to create a large wave you actually
probably want to be over fairly deep
water in terms of of doing that and so I
think to to some extent uh wake Surfers
may be self- selecting for deeper areas
of of the water but I've also heard that
the the aspect of the boat and the prop
wash can probably reach down a little
bit further uh you know into into the
depth of of the water as well so um
again that's not really my area of of
expertise um really at The Loon
preservation Committee in terms of loons
we are most concerned with the setback
you know of of 500 ft you know being an
absolute minimum and even at 500 feet
we're losing Lun nest you know to to
these wakes um every every departure you
know every minimizing of that 500 feet
means probably more Lon lest
lost representative Darby thank you and
representative um thank you Mr gole for
taking my question uh you mentioned um
you know reputable studies and so I I
also read um the study referred to as um
uh the sorry I have it right here the
numerical study of the impact of wake
surfing on Inland bodies of water um and
it was published by uh a group called
the scientific research uh publishing uh
organization um which I doing a little
research on that seems to be um based
out of China and um a paper um
publish uh um uh Journal so I was
wondering um if what what was the
criteria when you discounted that as a
non-reputable study yeah so um I have
read several um uh responses retorts to
to that study roundly criticizing that
that study um I think that the um the
conclusions from the study do not bear
any relation to the 200 foot
recommendation and again um when the
wave that's produced by that boat you
know is is um not accurate at more than
three boat lengths and and the authors
themselves State you know there is no
predictive value to wave height after
when you get 100 feet away uh I'm I'm
such just not certain how they could
come up with a 200 foot you know uh
limit from that based on the data it
seems that the conclusions that they
come are drawn from other studies you
know and again these are dubious Francis
at all and I believe that I have
citations for all of these studies and
the testimony that that I provided did
an overview you know a meta analysis of
all these studies um that's often done
in science when there are these
apparently contradictory results and
what this what the authors are
attempting to do is is find out what's
the consensus amongst all these studies
and which are outliers and and you know
the um that study the 200 foot uh
reference is clearly an outlier in those
studies and and you know um done as you
know created as as it is or funded by
the wig sport you know industry the
Marine manufacturers uh trade I I kind
of question the motives one of the
things that I found interesting with
that study is that throughout that paper
if you read it rather than use the term
planning they use the term planning and
and so I question any um uh uh any
critical review of that article before
it was published frankly I think that
the Publishers ought to be ashamed of
themselves for for publishing that it
has no scientific value whatsoever thank
you very much in my
opinion representative Khan did you have
a question thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for taking my question so what
is the rule right now uh what is the uh
the legislation right now the law I
believe it's just um you know that WG
sports are like any other boating
prohibited within 150 ft of of Shoreline
that's my understanding follow up Mr
chairman follow up so um so my
understanding is each person doing all
different thing their own way it's not
written exactly what they have to do
isn't it better to do this way that we
already uh everybody knows what they
have to do how they ser
I'm bring it to the
discipline I'm not sure that I
understand your question the question is
like my understanding is is there's no
law right now each Surfer doing all
different things that whatever they wish
or they choose right now if we if the
legislation passes 200 ft it'll be more
disciplined everybody will know that
what they can do or they cannot do yes
yes and and thank you for the question
and I think I I understand the gist of
that and our our um sense is that simply
200 feet is is just not at all adequate
you know for to protect our our lakes
and the original wake zone was was um
created long before these these wake
boats and and wake surfing H was
happening on our lakes in in successive
years these have become more powerful
they've created larger waves so every
year we have it seems like there are new
boats that are pushing those envelopes
and and limits um I don't think that
there's anyone in this room that would
argue that our Lakes are are healthier
today than they were 50 years ago and
you know Lakes have been dealing with
wind driven waves for 13,000 years since
the glaciers retreated and so the
question then is what has happened in
the last 50 years to cause this
downgrading of our lakes and I think we
need to to realize and and lay the blame
for that squarely on the cumulative
effects of human actions and I think WBS
are are one of the more um uh uh radical
examples you know of
that for a second time Mr Darby yes
thank you Mr chair very very briefly
this is lon specific um we talked about
Bo um wake boats self- selecting deeper
water and definitely I've heard the same
testimony um do loons how often do loons
choose shallower bodies of water we have
lots of bodies of water in this state
that have average depths of under 15 ft
so how of did lons choose those yeah so
loons really typically favor these
oligotrophic Lakes these low nutrient
deep um Lakes um and so uh I think that
in general you will find that loons and
and wake boats and and wake surfing
overlap to a high extent in New
Hampshire any other questions for the
speaker remember we have a lot of
speakers thank you Mr vogle appreciate
it thank you uh in favor representative
uh Linda Tanner
good afternoon representative my name is
representative Linda Tanner I'm from uh
Sullivan District 5 which represents the
beautiful towns of snipy and Springfield
and the wonderful lake of Lake snipy um
the reason I'm here and I've spoken
before you before um I'm not not a
scientist but I uh do recreate on the
Lakes uh since I was very young and
every place that I go nowadays around
the lake of any social event that I go
to in my district I hear the concern
what are you going to do about wake
surfing um it's been an issue that's
really come to the
Forefront and I want to explain that um
and this is probably a simple
explanation to scientists but um surfing
has traditionally been an ocean sport
and it's been an ocean sport because the
waves of the ocean have a lot of energy
to them have a lot of volume to them and
come in quite high and you know we've
all seen the surfing out in Maui Beach
where they're you know 30 foot waves or
100 foot waves um but recently uh and
just recently wake boats have been
developed and engineered to artificially
create those ocean type waves to support
surfing on freshwater lakes ponds and
rivers uh the major concerns that I've
heard from from the people in my area
have been the safety of other
recreational water uh activities like
paddle board Sports uh kaying fishing
swimming uh people just on their docks
or along the beach as well as the
environmental issues you're already
hearing about the shoreline um the and
and the quality of the
lake The increased size and force of
these ocean waves uh that are created
during wake surfing take a very long
distance to dissipate and
flatten um a distance of at least 500 ft
from Shoreline which I had in my other
bill um watercraft and other structures
has been suggested by recent studies and
and even they've asked as you've heard
for even more than that
um and that's to lessen the effects on
the safety of those using the lake and
the lakes are public property they're
they're of the state but we also have a
responsibility to use them safely and to
protect the quality of them I believe
the um the industry and the last time I
was here to to testify in this bill
before you suggested that a 15 foot
depth was what they suggest as efficient
for operation of the wake surfing um and
you can see from the handout that I gave
you with the boat tilted the way it is
with the power of the of the
propellers uh that the boat is always
pushing um Force down against the bottom
of the lake and if that lake is only 15
fet or 10t deep which some of our
glacial lakes are in in New Hampshire on
uh around the
sides it really turns up the bottom
creases to idity which you've heard
about turbulence not only disturbing the
loons but you can imagine what it does
to the bottom it brings all the
nutrients to the top um it ruins the
habitat for fish beneath the surface um
I saw a recent video out in
Wisconsin of a
underwater scenario where there was a
lot of vegetation for fish and a big
nice big Pike going through the the
weeds and then it shows a wake surfing
boat coming through in in their wake
surfing mode a lot of turbidity and
everything and after it passes and
things settle down the picture shows all
that habitat leaving and the the
turbulence still in the water so I I
highly support um some guideline as to
increased distance 150 ft from the
shoreline is about the distance if
you're on water a lot distance between a
towboat and a water skier that's about
150 ft so the 200 ft is is barely much
more 300 fet obviously would be two rope
links um away from the
shore um and I just think that we need
to get something going to keep the
quality of our Lakes to help reduce ion
bacteria blooms and preserve aquatic
habitat for fishing um and if it takes
you know some some sort of um compromise
let's go for it because we can't afford
to prolong the damage and stress on our
waterways that compromise the quality
and safety of our ponds our Lakes our
waterways and I think we need just
reasonable regulations I'm not asking to
ban wake surfing um but I think we need
reasonable regulations for wake surfing
that will allow for those who live on
the lake for those who use the lake to
use it safely to share the use of the
water to help prevent damage to property
wildlife habitat fisheries and maintain
our water quality New Hampshire Lakes
are an attraction for tourists and home
buyers and a large source of income for
local economies and it they're
irreplaceable fragile and natural
resources I urge you to look closely at
the bill before you and to work towards
a reasonable and workable solution to
save our Lakes thank you and I'm open to
questions
questions for the
representative representative
R thank you Mr chair thank you
representa for taking my question um you
just mentioned in your final remark that
this would be a solution but um we've
heard from the previous speaker that
it's not protective at all so I was
wondering do you think if this passes at
200 that it might be giving people a
false sense that we are improving
protections yes I think I you know my my
personal opinion is that 200 feet is
really going to do nothing other than
say okay wake surfing needs some sort of
reasonable regulation and at least it's
a 50 foot regulation more than regular
boats but as far as how that if if
you're really concerned about water
quality you're really concerned about
the safety of people on paddle boards or
on kayaks um you're concerned as I am
about the fish in the lake um then the
200 ft really isn't what you need and
recently uh Vermont has gone through
quite a review on their lakes and they
have posted uh their Lakes now they've
gone through rules and everything and
they suggest or they require 500 ft and
a 20ft depth and the 50 contiguous Acres
which was I built my original bill on I
think that's probably what we need but
as I said you know it's sausage time at
the state house and we'll see what comes
out representative Khan can you shut off
your mic please thank you representative
wolf thank you
um first question does Maine now have a
new regulation I believe they do but I
don't know exactly what it is I believe
they've just passed
one do you know what it is I I do I was
hoping you would ask answer for the
committee I believe it's 300 ft and 15
ft of depth 15t of depth which has been
passed by the state of Maine um you
think that's a sufficient distance
without
limiting severely the use of weight
boats I you know sufficient is a is a
kind of a funny word um I'm more
concerned about the quality of the lakes
and I'm concerned about the people in my
the constituents um you live on Lake
sunap as well and
um I just think that I I grew up water
skiing and it was a small Lake that we
had a small small long narrow Lake and
certainly everybody that used that Lake
knew certain times and could see out on
the lake when other people were out
water skiing and when they had the time
to go out and they had an open open spot
they went out um so you know people
adjust uh recreational boers adjust the
the weekends are are kind of crazy on
the Lakes but um I don't see this as a
as a TR tremendous burden on the wake
surfing
Community um to have an area that's that
that they can participate in their Sport
and still not damage our lakes and and
that's what's happening they're being
damaged representative Darby thank you
Mr chair um thank you representative
taner for taking my question um you
mentioned that you represent towns with
several Lakes um not only Lake sopi but
it sounds like smaller Lakes as well are
you concerned about um increasing the
offset Beyond 200 UND ft such that it
would push um push boats in and cause
conflict into a smaller channel for
example with a 300 foot um depth on on
even reasonable sized um you know 500
800 acre Lakes would that you know would
that cause a conflict based on what
you've uh witnessed in your District
well I've got to say the conflict has
been there's a there's a lake and spring
field New Hampshire Lake kuluk um and
it's it's one of those bowl Lakes where
the sides are shallow you know it
probably has 25 ft maybe at the most in
the center of the lake um and talking to
the constituents there what happened was
someone came in with with a wake booat
wake surfing boat and they went around
that Lake and around that Lake and
around that Lake and around that Lake
and caused a lot of turbulence a lot of
plant life came to the top one fellow
was telling me that he was trying to put
his dock out his swim Dock and he had to
fight the vegetation on the lake to to
get to where he wanted to put his dock
in and he at first he couldn't figure
out how it all came up from the bottom
and then he realized what happened and
on that particular Lake um there was a
lot of conflict with the neighbors a lot
of conflict with the neighbors to the
point where the person with the wake
surfing boat left that area um and I
think that's a real shame I think that's
you know we shouldn't pit neighbor
against neighbor um but people that ha
that have issues on the lake um you know
if that person had stayed in the middle
or had not been going around and around
in circles to to to do that and maybe a
little bit more reasonable in what they
did um I think you know things would
have been a lot different and a lot
different for the lake um sopy has a lot
of channels and you know a lot of our
Lakes have different Coes and channels
and one of the problems at lake sopy is
that um the Wake Surfers will often go
down a channel and the channels in the
lake get very um shallow and so you know
I I think you set regulations and I
think if people want to wake surve
they're going to find the areas to wake
surf they're going to enjoy it um and
not cause the conflict that we have
right
now you other questions for the
representative seeing none thank you
representative representative wolf can
you shut off your mic please thank you
speaking against Andrea Laro New
Hampshire Lakes
good afternoon chair and members of the
committee it's nice to see you all again
I'm Andrea Laro president of New
Hampshire Lakes we represent about 275
local Lake Associations and I'm here
today to testify in opposition to this
spb 431 as it's written and to request
an
amendment we request that be amended to
include at least a 300t setback and an
average lake depth requirement of at
least 10 ft these are the minimum
Provisions that seem like a fair and
reasonable compromise and that we are
willing to accept at this
time so over the F past few months uh we
have considered the opposition's
concerns and listen to your
committee thoughtfully discuss this
issue thank you for all the time you
have all put into this issue over this
session we supported your committee's
300 foot setback compromise on HB 1390
which unfortunately was not provided an
opportunity to be be discussed by the
Full
House I know your committee is well
versed about why a t 200t setback and no
depth
requirement leaves our health and the
health of our lakes and our loons at
risk so I'm not going to repeat that
so compromise means agreeing to give up
something you want if the other side
which has a different perspective gives
up something it wants we are
compromising at a 300t set setback we're
giving up 200 feet we started this
session supporting a 500t 20 foot depth
500t setback and 20ft depth
requirement so we're compromising 200 ft
here supporting an average lake depth of
at least 10 ft instead of a operating
depth of 20 ft were compromising we just
don't understand how codifying the wake
industry's wake responsibly
Campaign which recommends a 200 foot
setback is a compromise the 200 foot
setback recommended by the industry is a
generalized setback for wake surfing
across the
nation experience has shown that this
setback is inadequate in New Hampshire
we wouldn't be here today if the 200
foot setback that they're recommending
was working New Hampshire's Lakes are
LED and depended on for their clean and
clear waters We Believe higher standards
are required to keep them that way not
only are local Lake groups throughout
the state advocating for higher
standards Sur T States surrounding us
are putting in higher standards on April
3rd of this year the governor of Maine
signed into law a 300t setback and a
15ft depth requirement on April 15th the
Vermont wake Sports rule went into
effect this includes a 500 foot setback
and a 20 foot depth
requirement the health of the lake our
lakes here in New Hampshire is
deteriorating and we know that there are
a lot of reasons a lot of activities
that are contributing to this
deterioration we all must lean in and
work together and compromise to do what
is reasonable and fair and will help
stop this
degradation so this legislative New
Hampshire Lakes along with a lot of our
partners in this room we've been working
on a number of bills a number of bills
that are all aimed at at reducing our
Collective impact on the deterioration
of our Lakes we've worked on septic
bills fertilizer bills Shoreland
protection act bills and we've worked
with stakeholders and stakeholders
together were compromising to find
Solutions on these issues you would we
expect that that should be the same case
here on this issue we urge you to
continue to support a 300t setback like
you did earlier this session and to
include a minimum depth requirement
average depth requirement of at least 10
ft this will help to reduce the erosion
and bottom disturbance caused by wake
surfing and contributing to the
declining health of our Lakes by
amending this bill in this way you
demonstrate that you value compromise
and you value balancing the economy and
the health of our Lakes that's all I
have I'm to answer any
questions any questions for the
speaker representative
Darby thank you Mr chair um thank you M
lamro for uh taking my
question um I have a lots but I'm only
going to ask one because there's um
thank
you New Hampshire Lake uh New Hampshire
lakes also uh supports the Lakes host
program and one of the um one of the
provisions of the Senate bill is an
education component
in speaking to you know Captain D Ley
there are opportunities to provide that
education but it's but it's limited and
I was wondering if New Hampshire Lakes
would have any opportunity or the Lakes
host program more broadly would have any
opportunity to educate um wake um
possible wake Surfers on best practices
as they enter and leave
Lakes thank you for that question and
that's an excellent question um yes
through our lak host program we staff we
have about 500 volunteers 300 employees
at about 100 Lakes throughout the state
and um we meet and greet boers help them
prevent the spread of invasive species
and yes we could certainly um help
provide information to wake Surfers
about uh responsible wake surfing um we
would of course talk about the invasive
species issue first but then would happy
be happy to distribute
education representative R thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question and thank you very much for
attaching the Vermont and Maine bills
it's very helpful um that they've gone
to 300 what what was the original
distance so in Maine um you know there
was a I am not an expert on what
happened in Maine I know there was um a
lot of of back and forth in there
originally our counterpart main Lake
Society was also asking for a 500 um and
then it wiggled around a little bit and
and they landed on
300 you don't know what the original
distance was um in Maine oh it's 200
feet in M it was 200 so they went from
200 to 300 this is correct do you know
what it was in Vermont sorry Mr it's a
third followup but that's
okay I should know and I'm embarrassed
to say I do not know I don't know if
someone in this room knows but I can
certainly look into that thank you very
much any anyone else representative
wolf um thank you and thank you for
taking my question sure do you have any
idea as to what area amount of area
going from 200 to 300 feet would affect
on the lakes that is a really great
question I do not have the information
here um but I believe I have the start
of that information at our office and I
can um get that to
you thank you you're welcome any other
questions for the speaker seeing none
thank you very much thank
you speak in favor representative Tom
Dolan representative
thank you Mr chair and uh good afternoon
colleagues
uh
um I'm here today to support uh the
Senate Bill
431 about wake boating uh on our Lakes
uh there are definitely serious Environ
environmental impacts to both uh humans
and Wildlife but I'm going to let others
discuss that and you've already heard
some of that testimony let me offer you
some of my personal experiences and if
you could extrapolate that to other
property owners that are along the
shoreline of lakes I represent London
der which has no Lakes however I have a
a summer property in in Meredith and
have been uh been using that property
for several
decades uh but let me say clearly that I
do understand that the public lands and
water are free to be used by everybody
in the state but we also have to
consider the impact to those abing
Property Owners along the
Lakes these wake boats that we've been
talking about were introduced relatively
recently and they Inc they they you make
use of an incredible technology that
allow wake Surfers to ride the wakes
Behind these boats the boats sit very
low in the water and can utilize
sometimes sophisticated ballast devices
to create very large waves sounds like
fun but there are consequences these
large waves stir up the dirt and
turbidity and sediment making the water
unswimmable
and unusable for
consumption uh just for example my
grandchildren when they visit me at the
lake refuse to swim in the water if a
wake Boo's been going around because the
water is so dirty uh and the turity is
so uh
uh so much to accommodate them though I
had to install a $1,200 sediment
filter uh to take the sediment out of
the the water because we again we
consume the water for the plumbing of
the of the cottage and uh we cook in it
we use it and uh till very recently we
used to drink
it uh but and recently I had to pay a
contractor $600 to reinforce my Dock at
the lake because these wake boats
generate such large waves they wash over
the the entire Dock and make the dock
unstable and last summer for example
several docks along the shore of Lake wi
basaki were broken up by the waves and
there were uh pieces of dock floating in
the water which create a terrible Hazard
for boers and swimmers alike and God
help you if if you enjoy the lake as a
kayaker or a paddle boorder the Wake
boats uh if present
uh render that Recreation unusable and
unsafe in conclusion I'm not suggesting
that we ban these
boats let's just set up some rules so
that we may all enjoy the public
waterways there's enough room for all
parties to enjoy themselves the and when
asked why would I support a $200 a 200
foot U from the shore a restriction when
we've heard testimony that that won't do
that much much for us two words for you
guys baby steps I think that when we're
uh encouraging a change that is as by
some people's view as radical as we're
we're talking about restrictions here
sometimes you have to take the baby
steps try it out and come back next year
and say that 200 foot limit wasn't
enough we need to go to 300 ft or it was
okay let's leave it the way it is so I'm
happy that you're considering this uh
but please remember we have 400
colleagues that need to vote on this and
if and if they are not convinced and you
get um a defeat in the vote then you get
nothing so that's why I'm saying baby
steps uh try it out see how it works and
if it does start to work out then maybe
consider increas increasing
the uh the limit from the shore and
perhaps the depth of the water I'm
available to take questions if anybody
has any sentive R thank you Mr chair and
thank you representa good to see you if
an amendment came to the floor that did
extend it to 300 and had a depth
requirement is that something you would
vote for I certainly would yes thank
you representative wolf did you have a
question yes that's I put put it on so
um thank you does 300 foot help the
kayaker a 300 foot distance from Shore
does it give them an area um does it
does it help the kayaker enough that's
that would be the question I would think
to to consider and maybe not but it's
better than 200 feet or better than than
150 which is what we kind of have now uh
kayakers are uh really at risk in a in
the stability of their of their craft
when one of these boats comes by with
those with these huge
waves thank
you representative Darby thank you Mr
chair very briefly you mentioned that
you own property in Meredith what what
bay is that near what what uh area that
you've seen such turbidity in the water
that's in the area of Cummings coold
go um and what what happens if I
can if I could elaborate a little bit
what happens are people they launch
their
boats and they search around or they
already know but they they search around
for small Coes because they don't want
to be out in the middle of the lake it's
too much boat wash and too rough so they
find a small Cove and then they
basically go in a circle around inside
of that Cove and and and recreate with
their wake boats the the people that
live along that Cove have the the burden
of of dealing with the with the uh with
the waves from these wake boats in that
small Cove until they pack up and go
home for the day and that that's part of
the issue you think well you're on a big
lake lake wi basaki is the biggest lake
in the state what what's the big deal
but when you're in a when you're in a
small
Cove you're you're immensely impacted by
the activity of that Lake in that Cove
while that while that boats in
there son of w follow
thank you sir and thank you for taking
the question um you said that we go in
baby steps and I've been told that if
you don't make it now you're not going
to W with this
bill how do you know that the lake is
deteriorated in a year when you want to
come back with another bill this has
taken a long time for the
Lakes I
mean many many years ago you could see
bottom on stie at right 15
ft not happening anymore right I I great
question uh I would take testimony from
uh Dees see and and pro probably from
the Marine Patrol uh what they're seeing
but if the technology somehow could
support this and I'm a representative so
I know you're you're very limited but a
great thing to do would be if you could
get somebody to take a movie
a movie shot uh either with their cell
phone or with some
equipment uh
observe the Wake boats in uh in use and
then look at the water look at the
quality of the water the turbidity that
results from it and if you could show
that movie to each other uh the greatest
thing would be some type of a field trip
if you could do that but I know that's
really stretching it but uh uh that's
that's my
suggestion thank you represent
KH thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative taking my question uh we
hearing U the bill is for 200 ft and we
hearing about 300 ft is there any
compromise 250
ft uh I'd have to uh you have to get Tim
uh Senator Lang back to see as a a
sponsor if he wanted to change that
follow follow up would you vote for 250
ft if it is I would would vote for
anything that's better than what we got
right now thank
you any other questions for the
representative representative wolf for a
second time do you know what the
distance is that a ski booat has to be
from the
shore I believe it's I believe I'm not
exactly sure I believe it's 150 ft and
that's also from other boats too you
said at 300 you think it's 300 I don't
yeah come around yeah I'm not I'm not
exactly sure but I you you may you may
have someone behind me that has the
answer to
that anyone
else seeing none thank you
representative thank you for having me
speaking against the bill Bri Roser Lake
wiip pasak Association Bri
good afternoon thank you very much for
having me today my name is Bri Rossiter
I'm the conservation program manager for
the Lake wiip pasak
Association the Lake wiip pasak
Association or lwa is a 501c3 nonprofit
organization that is focused on
protecting Lake wiip masaki's water
quality and natural resources we do this
a variety of ways through monitoring
education stewardship and science-u
guided approach Coes for Land
Management our work serves and benefits
14 municipalities located in bellnap and
Carol counties and their 50,000
residents as well as hundreds of
thousands of visitors each
year we received numerous complaints
every single summer um about the
negative impacts of wake
surfing we do not support SB 431 because
we believe 200 ft is ineffective in
reducing the water quality impacts
resulting from Wake
boats we are not at all against wake
surfing we fully appreciate it as a fun
family activity and we also appreciate
all of the educational efforts that have
been undertaken by the water sports
industry and other associations but the
education aspect is not
enough everyone should be able to use
the lake some of our supporters say that
we are restrict ing one or some of the
bill supporters excuse me say that we
are restricting one activity over
another but this is not true if SB 431
passes as it stands it will continue to
impact swimmers kayakers and other
non-motorized
recreationalists again this bill does
not at all ban wake surfing will some
water bodies be impacted yes of course
but I think it's extremely important for
each of you to ask yourselves if these
activities should even be occurring on
these smaller water
bodies think of it this way would you
race a Ferrari on a gokart track
no I ask that you strongly consider
amending s sp4 31 to 300 ft with a depth
requirement of 10 ft to protect the
Ecology of our lakes and as a strong
economic driver for our state I would be
happy to take any questions any
questions for our speaker
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank
you speaking in support Ryan L
Liberty is it on you have to turn it so
the red lights on there you go um hello
everyone my name is Ryan Li Liberty I am
an eighth grader at Boral school I first
started wake wake surfing on vacation
back in 2018 when I was 8 my family and
I loved it so much we decided to get our
own boat our family has gotten into wake
surfing and we do a lot of wak surfing
on New Hampshire Lakes boating and wak
surfing has been a way for us to spend
time together as a family get off our
screens and do the sport we live I am
here in support of Senate Bill
431 I am here in favor of Senate bill
431 because I think this will make wake
suring safer without being pushed into
the middle I am also for this bill
because the restrictions now are 150 ft
the restrictions for this bill would
only be 50 more feet away from other
boats and dogs it doesn't ban us like
other bills try
to 200 ft would work well on a lot of
New Hampshire lakes that I surf on and
give everyone enough room to keep
everyone safe I think this bill would be
good for everyone that lives on the
lakes on or for so ERS like me and for
everyone else who goes out and enjoys
the water I appreciate your time and
consideration thank
you would you take questions uh yeah
sure okay anyone have questions from
Miss L Liberty presentative
Ryan thank you very much for your um
testimony thank you for taking my
question do you have any consideration
at all to 300 feet um I think for a lot
of the lakes that I surf on 300 feet
would be
um too much for like the lakes that I
surf on because I surf on lakes that are
closer to my
area thank you very much excellent job
any other questions representative W
thank you and thank you for taking my
question and thank you for your
testimony very well presented do you
have any concern about the deterioration
of Lake quality have you seen any
changes in your years on the
lake for um my years on the lake I
haven't seen that much of deterioration
in Lake water and like the um Clarity of
it but that's just what I've seen thank
you representative Darby thank thank you
Mr
chair I have six daughters I you're very
very brave I'm not sure that my
daughters would have been as Brave uh
this and I remember you testifying in
representative Hall as well I I uh
commend you um I missed where you're
from I was wondering um what can you rep
Town you're from and what lakes you what
you surf on um I'm from B New Hampshire
that's like near conquer and I surf on
um Pleasant Lake I've surfed on laki
cipe stuff like that thanks a
lot any other questions thank you seeing
none thank you for your
testimony speaking against Sheila Burke
kayaking Lake Region New Hampshire
Club all right good afternoon
uh is your light
on white should it be red here we go
Sheila Burke and yes I head up a uh a
large group of kayakers known as
kayaking Lakes Region New Hampshire and
Beyond we are heading into our fifth
season coming up uh and we have roughly
200 people in that group we kayak all
over New Hampshire also into Vermont
into
Massachusetts uh and sometimes even out
to Maine I also sit on the public Waters
access Advisory Board uh and I am in the
non-motorized Boating chair position
there and am a lifelong kayaker 30 years
in and Counting so today I thought I
would just provide some anecdotal
support for some of the commentary
that's been made about the safety uh
that can be impacted for kayakers when
we're talking about wake
Surfers
um and and before I go further I just
would like to say thank you for hearing
my oppos opposition to this bill uh we
know that it does not represent a
reasonable compromise to preserve and
restore the health of our Lakes uh and
it should be
amended
um as others have said before me you
know kayakers do tend to sort of hug the
shorelines of a lot of the Lakes um
rather than go into that Center Channel
where there tends to be lots of boat
traffic which can be hazardous uh and
with wake surfing out there it can be
even more so um also you know I I guess
goes without saying that um the
shorelines and and uh animal life around
the the Lakes as well is impacted as
others have said so um anyway my
personal story is as I said anecdotal
but last season I was pulling my boat up
off of uh the water down at cattle
Landing Lake winaki which is where I
live and
um you know without any warning
whatsoever a tsunami style wave came
sort of you know barreling up from
behind me knocked me sideways swamped
the boat and necessitated my friends to
kind of come forward and help you know
put the the water out of the boat help
me get right and you know get back on my
way and pulling the boat out of the
water looking back uh out across the
water we saw a wake booat that had been
sort of zooming through uh the Catal
landing area and bear Island which is a
very small kind of you know bottleneck
right there it's it's rather deep but
someone was zooming through there was
and so about 200 feet offshore maybe
even a little bit more was where this
boat was so this is really just some
personal evidence that this kind of wave
action really can do some damage I'm not
a small person you know and I'm pretty
strong but to have been almost knocked
over by this wave is actually quite
quite um disturbing so you know that's
really the story I wanted to share today
uh we know too that others in the group
who do the kayaking in other re other
regions have commented on the same thing
I hear stories all the time about the uh
safety concerns that kayakers have when
it comes to wake surfing um you know had
the um you know had I not been sort of
on my feet too with you know what
happened at Catal Landing this this
incident could have been a lot more
serious so really that's it I mean for
this reason I am in opposition to this
bill um I again believe it should be
amended um According to some of the
testimony that we've heard from others
such as Andrea and uh I realized this is
a rather complex problem that's been
sort of longstanding there's been a lot
of debate so that's all I can add to the
discussion today and I would be happy to
take some questions if there are
any any questions representative Darby
thank you Mr chair um as a member of the
public water access Advisory Board you
I'm sure you recognize the importance of
maintaining public access to to our
Waters so what do you recommend for
sharing you know non-motorized kayaking
as well as you know wak surf uh and
other motorized uh sports like
wakeboarding and water skiing how can
those be shared sharing in terms of so
everybody so can everybody can enjoy the
water yeah yeah uh look I I think if I
had my brothers would go the the way of
Vermont and Maine you know Vermont as as
we've talked about earlier today um
happens to have the most restrictive uh
wake surfing regulations in the country
uh we know that that came about as a lot
of Grassroots activity and uh you know
took a while to come to the to the four
uh but yeah that would be my ideal
um but you know this is New Hampshire
and we have a whole different style
different way of going about business
and you know certainly I'm a huge
proponent of of increasing maintaining
restoring access to all the water bodies
across the lake so your question is a
very good one representative um you know
we we do need to come to some sort of
compromise uh solution here I think
that's why we're all here today um and
to cut to the chase I would be uh
personally very gratified if I could see
a 300t setback okay with you know some
depth requirement there I would leave
that to others to decide there's studies
that would support you know varying
depths we know Vermont is at a 15ot
depth that' be ideal uh if that's
possible great but 300 ft at a at a
minimum for me for as a setback from the
shore I think would be a good middle
ground
sure anyone else
seeing none thank you for your testimony
thank you speaking in favor Steven
Raymond thank you uh good afternoon the
record I'm Steve Raymond of Manchester
New Hampshire I'm here today in support
of Senate Bill 430 31 thank you for
hearing from me I'd like to give you my
perspective on the issue of wake boats
and water sports based on my unique and
relevant personal and professional
background I'm a New Hampshire native
and since 8 have spent my Summers on
Lake winnisquam I grew up water skiing
wakeboarding and tubing and uh my love
of the lake started at a young age and
has never gone away I competed
nationally in wakeboarding in my younger
years and had the opportunity to share
my love of the sport with others and
make lifelong friends I've also mentored
many children through the years through
the sport um I've actually owned a wake
booat for 25 years so those who say it's
just been around for a few that's
inaccurate um wake Boo's been around for
25 years or or even a little more about
six years ago I started wake surfing as
wake surfing is a great sport that can
keep you active and healthy um you can
experience it with a lot more people
because it's less intimidating and it's
very easy to learn um my 13-year-old
daughter has wakeboarded and wake surf
since 5 and absolutely loves her time in
the water which we're also Avid paddle
boarders so despite again what you've
heard um we paddle board every morning
on the lake every afternoon we're out
there all the time um we love every
aspect of our time on in the water
whether motorized or non-motorized uh
over the past 25 years I've worked
exclusively in the environmental
remediation industry um which
specializes in the cleanup of impacted
groundwater um surface water and soil
I'm responsible for implementation of
those types of projects around the
country um many of those projects
include restoration of wetlands and
shorelines so because of this unique
background I understand water related
issues that impact our shorelines that
are incorrectly being attributed to wake
boats um by individuals or groups
looking to restrict wake boats I hear
opponents that they are concerned about
damage to the environment as it pertains
to erosion and impacts of private
property and that's a major driver for
the opposition that we're hearing today
what I would hope opponents of wake
boating are learning about are the
number of other factors that contribute
to erosion more than wakeboarding ever
could these factors include improper
development improper Shoreline
improvements vegetation tree removal
storm water runoff ice wind and water
levels for example ice is a factor that
many don't think of because they don't
see it or understand it uh ice forms
around the rocks in the winter um if
water levels fluctuate it will pull
rocks off the shore destabilizing the
soil above or it can push rocks up onto
the shore d destabilizing the soil Below
in addition during the Spring thaw ice
drifts moving due to Quick melting um or
due to wind can pull up or push rocks
and soil from the shore in addition to
ice damage irrelevant over the past year
in New Hampshire due to higher than
average rainfall and higher water levels
uh erosion resulting from high water and
wave action for sustained winds excuse
me has caused significant erosion of
shorelines in very short periods of time
the constant battering of waves at a
high velocity and frequency driven by
the wind contributes significantly more
impact to our shorelines than a wave
from a boat can for example a boat wake
surfing traveling up and down the lake
over a period of time directs waves to a
particular spot on Shore for a small
fraction of time when the boat is moving
right in front of that spot however
during a high wind event and even more
impactful a high wind in water event
waves are directed at the shore for the
entire period the wind is blowing in the
direction of the shoreline being being
impacted as an example um I've included
some pictures in my testimony um this is
from two recent storm events um in
January this year on Lake winnisquam
where more than a foot of soil was
removed off of the beach and we're
hearing this from a lot of homeowners on
Lake winnisquam this has nothing to do
with wake boats there was no one wake Bo
boating in January this year um the high
water levels in the Wind It causes
significant erosion and these are the
factors that you know you know really
need to cons considered when hearing
this testimony um the argument of
restricting wake boats to prevent
erosion I believe is being used by
opponents as a scare tactic for those
who are not familiar with the issue of
shoreline erosion on New Hampshire Lakes
um I'm happy to tell you more or answer
any questions thank you for hearing from
me today and the time you all taking to
learn more about the issues thank you
any questions from Mr
Raymond yes representative thank you uh
Mr chair thank you for taking my
question
I've um I understand you've been wake
boarding um for a long time um and I I
was wondering um the this bill talks
about wake surfing um and wake boarding
is covered um under the the same
restrictions as um as water scheme um it
it involves holding onto a rope um
typically jumping wakes and so I was um
I was wondering when I think you said
that you've been wake surfing for three
years so I'm wondering when or six years
I'm sorry so I'm wondering when you got
the the Wake boat that allowed sort of
the the um the large wakes directly
behind the boat which is the definition
of wake
surfing yeah thank you for your question
I I think some of it's a misconception
so wake boating you actually want to do
something similar to wake surfing you
want a large wave because you're using
the Wake as a basically a ramp just like
if you were going off a ski jump or
something like that uh on the slopes um
so wake boats have been making larger
wakes for years I think the bigger issue
now is the popularity of wake surfing um
it's so easy for people to do it's a lot
of fun it's a great family sport indivi
there are more individuals that are
getting out there with wake surf boats
on the lake the more boats you have the
more people doing it you know more
people may you know not like what they
see but I think that that is what has
attracted the attention is just the the
quantity of people doing it and just you
know our Lakes have gotten busier um you
know Through The
Years thank you any other questions
representative rang thank you Mr chair
and thank you for taking my question um
you had in your in your written
testimony and thank you for providing
that you said that you've from what
you've read and heard it uh erosion
seems to be incorrectly attributed to
wake boating can you cite some of those
sources um that you know show you know
that you've read that wake boating
doesn't contribute to those issues so I
guess what I'm saying my testimony is
that you I've I've been involved in
these hearings for some years um
individuals always come up and they're
talking about erosion and erosion being
attributed to wake boats my professional
experience is in you know what I do what
and my time I've spent on the Lakes
growing up what I do for work I think
it's it's a misrepresentation that wake
are cusing this shoreline erosion I you
know there are so many other factors
that contribute to erosion and I think
also if you look at any boating in
general boats have the ability to make a
large wake even non wake boats I mean
you go on wiip or cipe or Winn
Squam Squam on a weekend there are boats
going every which direction boats tubing
causing wakes so to to say that that you
know now is what's causing these erosion
problems I think is what individuals are
using because it has an effect right who
sits in this room and hears you know
erosion and thinks oh who cares about
erosion on our Lakes we all care about
it I think it's being used as a reason
to ban wake boats and not and and
not I I guess I guess that's my my
feeling and that my my professional
opinion you know my my professional
experience is that these other factors
contribute more you know no one looks at
the development all the people that
aren't following the shorelands
protection act go along all these lakes
and look at the development that's
occurring there's less soft shorelines
there's more rigid shorelines right
people build these big retaining walls
on their property that doesn't allow
waves to actually like lose velocity it
just bounces them right back into the
lake there's a lot of factors that
contribute and um I don't think people
are looking at those issues as a whole
thank you representative Khan then
representative wolf thank you Mr chair
Derby can you shut off your mic thanks
thank you Mr Raymond for taking my
question uh question is if you you live
show that you live in Manchester
newshire and if you live near the lake
just say Lake wi nasaki and you are a
property owner would you have the same
feeling uh that what you are saying
because some of the things uh that we
are hearing here about the loan
preservation you know if you can mention
that is the loan is endangered you know
in this situation yeah thank you for
your question so I am a property owner
on Lake winnisquam um my my family has
been on the lake I actually was lucky
fortunate enough years ago to get my own
property in the lake so I do understand
um the issues um I remember being as a
kid if we saw a loon it was like the
greatest thing in the world and now you
know we see loons you know quite
frequently um he mentioned chicks I can
tell you that the people that do water
sports on Lake Winn Squad
they know when there's chicks and
everyone will stop immediately and go by
if and go by at no wake speed I can tell
you there's a lot of people that just
drive their boats around and they will
fly right through those chicks like they
don't even know they exist I think most
water sports enthusiasts are we love the
lake that's why we're on the lake we we
care for the lake we so you know I I
like to think that most are stewards of
the lake but just like anything there's
individuals that come and they don't
follow the rules um they don't know what
they're doing they probably shouldn't be
out in any boat and a lot of times um
that that will you know give a bad wrap
to the sport because of you know few bad
activ representative wolf thank you Mr
chair and uh thank you for taking my
question I understand that there are
many many factors that are affecting a
lake run off from roads run off from
gutters in a house um
all types of things that affect erosion
that affect water quality
Etc there he there seems to be quite a
difference here of opinion would you
think in your professional experience
that reducing the distance from Shore
would help not completely solve the
problem but be a step in the right
direction from an erosion standpoint I
think not at all I I don't think that
would help at all if if you go to any
Lake in New Hampshire on a day where we
have 20 mph sustained
winds and and watch the water pound on
the shore and then go watch waves from a
wake booat hit the
shore it'd be very difficult for me to
say wow that's what's contributing to
the
erosion follow up and then
representative l montain i I'm not
talking about
the natural phenomenon that occur like
high winds MH high water levels last
summer that we had that were
extraordinary and I'm not saying that
you stop weights but would you improve
the
situation if you did not if you mov the
Wake further
out I guess in all due respect I don't
understand what situation we'd be trying
to improve at that point by just moving
another 100 ft out okay thank you
present BL
montain thank you um would you consider
it such an imposition to move it another
100 feet out to say 300 feet in order to
perhaps protect people who are trying to
swim or paddle or kayak close to the
shore so in my case thank you on my case
in Lake Winter Squam likely not but on
many lakes in New Hampshire yes and
there there is a safety Factor like
everyone's saying the more you push
boats into the middle the more congested
that is I mean I I also hear like the
safety of kayakers and paddle borders I
I don't know that many kayakers paddle
borders that only hug the shore within
you know 20 feet of the shore they like
to go across the lake through the lake
so I I guess are we going to make a zone
for K I mean so when a if a kayaker is
out in the middle of the lake it's my
job as a motorized boat owner to make
sure that I am staying a certain
distance away from them so just pushing
us more like everyone has to share the
water I guess from like a kaying and
safety a kaying point I don't see how
pushing people further out into the
middle makes it any safer unless you're
going to tell me that you know kayaks
are only going to stay within 50 ft of
shore now so that people can wake Boo in
the middle of the lake I mean it's a
it's a sharing of the resource there's
rules in place quite honestly and I'm
sure when you talk to Marine Patrol the
biggest thing is enforcing the current
rules if people follow the rules it's
safe and it's protective of of the
lake but there's people that
don't thank you any other questions
saying none thank you for your testimony
Mr thank you
in opposition as written Elizabeth
Harper Lake sopee protective
Association there we go all right um my
name is Elizabeth Harper I'm the
executive director of the lake sopy
protective Association where a non
profit organization that focuses on
preserving and enhancing the
environmental Integrity of the lake sopy
Watershed we have over 900 members um
before joining lspa I was an
environmental science professor at New
England college for seven years uh and
before that I was a professor of
fisheries and wildlife biology at pulsus
College in the ader andex um I'm here
today to ask you to oppose s SP 431 is
written and to consider amending the
bill to provide meaningful protection
for a shared water
resources the environmental impacts
caused by wake surfing have devastating
long-term consequences that are
completely avoidable I think that
completely avoidable part is really
important we heard a long list of all of
the stressors to our lakes in the
previous testimony those are absolutely
of concern some of those things we can
prevent we can control some of them are
much more challenging too this is an
opportunity here to address one of the
many issues that threatens our Lakes the
200 foot setback proposed by us
431 doesn't represent a meaningful
compromise the best available science
suggests that setbacks of 500 to 1,000
ft are needed to mitigate these impacts
and that wake surfing should not take
place in waters that are less than 20 ft
deep anything less than a 300t setback
with a 10-ft average depth doesn't
provide any meaningful improvement from
what we have now 50 ft added to that
distance really doesn't provide a
meaningful change
the study that Fay at all did that has
been promoted by the wakes sport
industry is widely cited um as
justifying that 200 foot setback and
it's considered to be exceptionally poor
science I won't go into the details
Harry vogle did an excellent job of
summarizing um the scientific
perspective on on that very flawed study
the recommendation to limit wake Sports
to areas 500 ft from shorelines with
depths of 20 ft on bodies of water at
least at least 50 acres has been
supported by Michigan's Department of
Natural Resources by Vermont's
Department of Environmental Conservation
and numerous scientific studies the best
science is summarized very well in a
thorough literature review of over 50
sources that were synthesized by the
state of Michigan's Department of
Natural Resources in July
2023 the science is pretty clear in
terms of the impacts and what we need to
do um I understand that sometimes
compromise is necessary but if we're
going to make compromises it needs to
involve a meaningful Improvement and 200
ft doesn't represent that um I won't
belabor other points that have already
been covered but um I'm happy to answer
questions this time I'm going to ask a
question thank you for taking it um you
mentioned 500 feet you mentioned 300
feet the bill says 200 feet I know
someone's going to ask you so I will
would you support a 300
foot yeah so would say that we could
consider a 300 foot distance to be a
meaningful Improvement on our existing
regulations I wouldn't say that it's
sufficient um but I would say that it
would represent a meaningful Improvement
thank you any other questions for the
speaker representative Darby and
represent um thank you Mr chair um thank
you for taking my
question um you you talked early in your
testimony about I think you said
devastating long-term consequences can
you talk about um how the lake would
actually repair itself and how long it
would take to repair itself if there is
no change you know well these things are
always complicated but I think the the
areas that I'm most concerned about are
these small lakes there are small lakes
where even one wake booat acting
irresponsibly could completely destroy
the fish habitat that's available even
in just a single season um restoring
fish habitat is not simple it's not
inexpensive
of you disturb sediment and that can
create cyanobacteria blooms that can
alter the entire food chain um zop
Plankton and phytoplankton are the base
of the food chain in these systems when
you start to change the nutrient loads
of these Lakes it it's not something
that just changing your actions in the
future can fix they're ecosystems that
once Disturbed many times oftentimes
can't be returned to their original
state
followup thank you Mr chair um thanks
again um you you referenced the uh um
University of Michigan study with over
50 sources um can you state how many of
those sources claimed that uh 200 ft was
sufficient
none thank you Mr chair um can you tell
me I've been thinking about this since
Andre was speaking
earlier how long was the 200 foot ban in
place in the state of Maine and what
precipitated what caused them to rewrite
the legislation and to add another 100
ft to that
law I don't know the length of time um
but I think similarly as for many many
states and it's not just Maine and and
Vermont and you know that have been
discussing this or Michigan there's
States all over the country that have
have lakes that have been concerned and
I you know they're hearing the same
thing that we are in our Lake
Associations a lot of people that are
concerned about the impacts of these
boats environmentally and from a safety
perspective and once there's a lot of
public concern then there's an interest
in diving into the science the way that
this works in different states in some
states it's you know Department of
Natural Resources that's responsible for
doing that study and bringing a bill to
um to the house in New Hampshire it
works a little bit differently
um and so it's it's the process is
different in different states but in
general it's a large number of members
of the public raising concerns and then
that leads us people in our position to
delve into the science and to see what
the issue is and then to try to work
with folks like you to come up with a
reasonable
solution representative Ron thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question um the previous speaker made
some comments that we've heard from many
other uh people about that wake boats
aren't really a a a relevant contributor
to erosion and Shoreline issues that
it's ice high water uh wind things like
that can what from your scientific
perspective and from your role on Lake
copy can you comment about the relative
um impact wake surfing has relative to
those other natural
components yeah I mean I think it is
really important that we all recognize
that there are a huge number of factors
all of those things that you listed that
can cause erosion and the more
development that we have you know just
as one of the previous speakers
explained um you know the more erosion
we do have the what wake boats are doing
the the energy and the waves that they
can produce they don't always it depends
on how they're being used but they can
produce wakes that have high energy and
it's it's not even the height of the
Waves that's the issue it's the power
it's the energy that's in those waves
and the force with which it hits the
shoreline and that is at a much higher
rate and if you want to dig into the
numbers it's it's in that study but um
it it's much greater than many of those
other impacts it doesn't mean that those
other impacts aren't important and don't
have have impacts but just because those
are are important impacts doesn't mean
that weight boats don't cause those
problems as
well thank you any other
questions thank you for your testimony
thank you you want to just do
the want to speak right but do you want
to
H
okay we're going to temporarily recess
and I do have one two like five six more
cards but if some of you were here
earlier we have an amendment to a PRI
bill so we're going to take a temporary
recess until we finish the voting on The
Pri bill then we're going to immediately
go back so if you want to hang around I
don't think it'll take too long
all right did
you you need to bring the other one back
in all right GNA recess uh I already
recessed that already recessed that okay
I'm going to call to order that I want
to reconvene the hearing we been have
have on Senate
Bill
539 and the chair
recognizes Senator Murphy
thanks chairman it's been a it's going
to see you all after the last hour delay
hope you're enjoying the uh the
hearing uh so I'm happy to present uh
Amendment
16388 which you'll notice in your name
representative Renzo yep um and as
promised this bill this amendment
removes any reference to the Loan Fund
the dam maintenance fund it retains the
language that president of mon
requested now it's on line uh 30 29 and
30 on page 1 and it does reference uh
easements uh being transferred as well
as the dam itself which was the request
of the
department any uh any questions on the
amendment first want you maybe have a
look at it for a minute or two well
while I get accustomed to the heat in
here uh
hello
okay need motion anyways we don't have a
motion
all
all right uh this is this is not a
normal way of doing things uh
representative
lontine uh representative Ryan has a
question probably well you might as well
if she asked me if I ask you if you will
ask answer a question so all
right she representative Ryan has a
question you accept question from
representative Ryan say yes please say
yes so I could get out of here oh I pass
a note sorry um thank you for taking my
question does this does this amendment
answer your earlier question about the
Bill yes thank
you all right are there any questions uh
by members of the committee on the
amendment seeing
done will the clerk please call the role
we haven't got an OP to pass oh that's
right I'm so many that's I am so I left
the room and I got needed
raining
uh someone needs to make a motion have a
motion about to
pass will you make the motion yeah I'll
make a motion of a to pass on Senate
Bill
539 is there a second I'll
second is there any is there an well
motion on the amendment will someone
please I'll move the amendment um I just
want to make a point of order y I'm
sorry to be so anal I think we're still
in the hearing and I think we need to
start the executive
session you're Absolut yes
yeah in
my point of orders first of all repes
representative representative Bale we uh
I
according to the rules we have to agree
on
having on having an executive session on
this bill at this
time yes for the record Mr chair we
agree on heading into executive session
at this time on Senate Bill
539 as amended thank you very much and I
will open the executive session on
Senate Bill 539
and well you close the other one
oh and and close the uh the the hearing
on Senate Bill
539 uh we have already
heard the testimony on the amendment
from uh Senator
uh motion okay I'll I do want I do need
a mo or a motion of ought to pass again
representative I make Mo to pass can I
second can you second and I have an
amendment motion on the amendment from
representative rung yeah I move uh
Amendment 20241 1638 H yeah and do I
have a second I have second for
representative Dunley is there any
discussion on the
amendment there being none CL please
call a roll on the
amendment okay um yes on the
amendment is 1638 representative harb
yes representative gold yes
representative organ yes cler votes yes
representative KH
yes representative wolf yes
representative M yes representative
Donnelly yes representative dun
he's not here okay uh representative
Vale yes representative run yes
representative
Kelly yes representative Simpson yes
representative Baldwin yes
representative
Derby yes okay representative ho yes
representative ltin yes representative
lit yes uh representative Ryan yes and
the chair yes it's 19 to Zer motion
passes 19 Z motion
passes uh
is on the uh on the bill ought to pass
the motion of ought to pass as
amended do he wish to speak
uh um the pass as
amended y very quickly I just uh
looks like a pretty straightforward bill
that's an enabling sort of legislation
for towns um solve some problems and I
appreciate the amendment the work done
on the amendment as well uh simplify the
bill and that's it thank
you and on your
second no further no further
comment and any for any further
discussion seeing none
on ought to pass as amended please call
the
RO ought to pass as amended
representative harb yes representative
Golds yes representative organ yes cler
votes yes representative KH yes
representative wolf yes representative
MCU yes representative Don
yes representative
Vale yes representative Rong yes
representative Kelly yes representative
Simpson yes representative Baldwin yes
representative Darby
yes representative hoit
yes uh representative lontine yes
representative
lit yes representative Ryan yes and the
chair yes it's 19 to zero motion
passes second we can't
uh we did the other we'll try we'll try
the consent um as far as the blurb if
you want do you want to write it if not
I'll write it because being Frugal I
copied the house version of the bill
originally and cut out all the things
about the loan and andn it's available
now so you can write it yeah I'll do it
so that's already done so no uh we close
the hearing on how
a Senate Bill
539 thank you and thank you for waiting
uh Mr chairman members of the committee
thank you very much for your helping
assistance I appreciate it thank
you I'll now
uh take up Senate
Bill
4311 going to reconvene Senate Bill 431
do you want to take over do you want
to
okay all right here okay this this is
McDonald uh representative John McDonald
where'd he
go representative
McDonald are you here there he
is the floor is
yours my apologies Mr chairman I was
talking to uh captain
dunlevy my name is uh John McDonald and
I'm the representative from Carol
district 6 which is uh wolfb in t New
Hampshire I'm a lifelong resident of uh
wolf pretty much since I was about two
years old I guess so that's lifelong and
I'm in support of this uh this
particular Bill SP
431 um if you know me I'm also a strong
supporter of uh boing safety keeping our
legs clean and other the important
things that are important to our our
Lakes uh I'm not an engineer but I do
have some boating experience
I graduated from the United States Coast
Guard safe boarding school I worked in
the marol for many years in fact uh I
was one of the people that hired Captain
dunlevy so if you're wondering where he
got all that knowledge you're looking at
it right here uh over my career my law
enforcement career I've done a lot of
issues that have been involved in the
boting some that pretty important I was
part of uh theing the moing program
several years back uh the DB testing for
boats uh the rafting rules and regul Rel
basaki and probably one of the most
important ones the ski craft which was
the old jet skis and uh I went all over
the state putting signs up prohibiting
signs and also did a public hearings on
approximately 30 bodies of water
throughout the state uh I would go up on
the state police plane hang out the
window and take pictures of the lake
with a with a camera it's pretty cool
but one of the things that I learned
from that whole program the ski craft
one is uh how important education is uh
you hardly ever hear any problems with
jet Skys anymore and that's all due to
education and I was impressed and one of
the reason I co-signed this bill was uh
some of the factors that are contained
within it uh the most important one is
probably
uh the one that says uh less than 50
acres I believe that section right there
will probably eliminate around 800
bodies of water in the state of New
Hampshire from having this type of
activity conducted on them uh if you get
rid of that bill they're still open to
these type of activities uh another one
that I support is the 200 ft of the
shoreline of the dock we've heard a lot
of talk about that it should be 300 it
should be 500 uh New Hampshire is not
the only state that's considering 200
feet I think it's also uh Georgia
Tennessee and South Carolina have a 200
foot limit and then the most important
one again is is the education part of it
with the Department of Safety standing
up and moving forward with uh providing
education programs uh I know over the
past year or so two years I usually go
on to some of my local Mariners just to
say hi and I've seen a lot of
displays uh put on the Marin pushing the
200t rule uh with Panthers and handouts
and those things aren't cheap they
didn't have to do that uh I would say
they probably all the me put together
probably close to $100,000 they put in
education and I just don't think that
we've given them enough time to get the
word out about the 200 fet uh also in
the uh my lustrious Creo on Lin basaki I
was a captain of a a tourbo 65t TBO that
was just recently sold and we go out
every day and I can tell you about a Lon
nest and around that loon nest every day
there's on a nice sunny day there's
probably 60 boats anchored around that
lon's Nest so I don't think we can blame
this all on Wake boats on that type of
activity
uh I you've talked a lot about Vermont
uh that is the strictest uh law in the
in the United States at the present time
there are only 32 bodies of water in the
entire state of amont that can use have
that type of activity all the other ones
are banned just by the infl of that law
um so I'd ask you to support this this
bill uh don't change it let it go
through Let It Go through for a couple
years see how it works uh you know give
the people the opportunity to get
educated uh I would add if you're going
to do an amendment do not put a depth
requirement that's going to be
impossible to prove in court if you give
somebody a ticket uh none of the maps
are accurate and it's just like getting
a speeding ticket you're going to have
to prove that you're certified to use
the radar and the radar is certified and
you can't prove depth by just bringing a
map a liquin masaki a Squam a sunabe and
uh you know showing that that depth on
the map uh a lot of folks aren't aware
of what we've got for depths on some of
our Lakes uh Lake Quin basaki is 44,400
Acres Squam Lake is 6,790 Acres Newfound
lake is 4,450 Acres
Lake witer Squam is
4,237 acres and sop is 4,130 acres and
then it drops down the next win's oopy
uh Lake Wentworth great East Lake Conway
Lake Mary meeting Moma Bo Lake uh Silver
Lake Province Lake and then Walky W is
at 928 Acres uh so we've still got some
pretty good size lakes and I can't
believe that uh this particular activity
is damaging the uh the shoreline uh the
way everyone is accusing of
uh I guess the last thing I'll say is uh
Dees uh I see their responsibility of
protecting our shorelines and our lakes
and on the letter that I got um they're
staying neutral and it seems that
they're okay with the 200 foot uh limit
on the boats and uh again I I respect
thees and I would think that if there
was a problem with erosion pollution the
environment on the Lakes they'd stay up
step up and say yeah this is the problem
got to address it thank you
are there any questions by members of
the
committee
representative rung first okay thank you
Mr chair and thank you representative
for taking my question we've heard
testimony um from a few people that 200
feet is not protective and there is a
suggestion to go to amend the bill to
extend it to 300 feet if that Amendment
came through would it be one you would
support on the floor no thank you
rep repres representative Darby thank
you Mr chair thank you representative
McDonald for taking my question um with
respect to education um and best
practices do you think that um that
environmental imp potential
environmental impacts could be
considered in terms of the impacts and
the
education yes they should I'm I'm
positive they probably still do I've
been done voting education for a while
but I'm sure they must address the safe
wakes the distance of the wakes the
damage of the wakes and things like that
yes thank you the
question representative
ltin um thank you given um how important
the education is um will you be
advocating for more um educational funds
to the Department of Safety for this
purpose uh yes I would um and also so
when I we need more people to do
education every law enforcement job is
suffering because they can't hire police
officers uh the time when I first
started with Marine Patrol which was
1977 we had 75 officers and now I think
they're down to 14 or 15 so we've got to
really try to attract uh more more
people for enforcement of the laws you
can pass all the laws you want but if
you don't have anyone to enforce them
you know what good are they
followup then will be you be advocating
in the next budget to increase the
funding for Marine Patrol officers and
education of course yes
okay is there any other questions by
members of the committee they seeing
none thank you very much thank you for
your
time I would also
uh ask the committee members to restrict
their questions to the contents of the
bill and not uh somebody else's opinion
on whatever you uh you know whether you
like the stars or not who do you like on
the next uh the next election
uh is
the Gary
York in
opposition sir car York
you can't be outside well I'll call the
next
one Frank
lay in
support she's not
feeling um thank you I'm uh having me
here allow me to speak um my name is
Frank lame um uh I'm a homeowner on uh
new in Newbury on Lake sopy I've been
there for 20 years I'm also on the board
of the lake sopy protective
Association and I'm also the business
and industries rep in business and
industry associations representative to
the Lakes management advisory Council
and I would like to point out that the
Lakes management advisories committee uh
endorsed uh representative Tanner's bill
with the 500 foot that back in the 20ft
depth I'm a business owner and I been
that way for 35 years and I'm Pro
business and um for the Boating industry
and the Marine trades but I think we
have to uh get wake boats and uh wake
surfing in particular uh within strong
limits so that they uh can um coexist
with us I have friends with wake boats
and they follow rules and uh they stay
away from the shore and it works out
fine
line um I would say that uh the report
from the Marine industry presented uh
from everything I've seen and heard is
not valid uh the state biologist David
Nells did testify during the Senate
portion of this and did find that the
Minnesota study was the most
comprehensive and the most uh
detailed um I wanted to point out one
other thing and that's the cob bacteria
in the state which is increasing uh
Again David Neils is right on top of
that and uh we've had a lot of blooms in
the last few years and why are we while
are we complaining about erosion and
turning things up uh it basically turns
up the nutrients phosphorus nitrogen
that get trapped in that soil that's at
the bottom of the lake and when it does
it feeds things and cob bacteria is one
of the strong things it does it does
feed so I think that's something has
been brought up and I wanted to put it
put there um I don't think this you
should look at this as an argument of us
against them it's uh what we're trying
to do is responsible voting and come up
with rules that can satisfy both parties
uh I have no problem I'm a sailor and I
really don't like going across their big
wakes but that's my problem okay I I can
live with it as long as we follow rules
so I'm for the 500t setback and I'm for
the 24th depth regulation um thank for
listening and I'll take any questions
okay any questions by members of the
committee representative R thank you Mr
chair um and thank you for taking my
question your last comment said you
supported the 500 foot setback and I
think 20 foot depth um this bill is
about 200 foot setback um with no depth
and so would you do you support this or
a greater distance I I support a greater
distance than 200 ft
and the depth of 20
ft any other questions seeing none thank
you very much thank
you support of the
bill John
Wally R Marine trade
good afternoon Mr chairman members of
the committee my name is John Wally you
probably remember that by now um I was
going to read this to you but that's
going to be really boring and it's being
passed around and I feel as though my
experience on the water has a lot of
value to this conversation so um I'm
going to start off with 200 uh we are in
support of 200 it seems to be this
confusion of who's supporting 200 and
supporting 500 and 300 and I don't know
but the Marine trades Association
supports 200 feet
uh I want to point out that boating as a
whole also has safe passage 150 ft we
can all agree upon that correct and
boats Don't just run across the
shoreline at 150 fet from Shore they go
out in the middle they go in different
places they go to dinner they do all
these different things just like 200
feet will do it creates a new minimum
standard but people and in my position
as a person that works at the marinas
it's my job to teach people about their
boats how to operate them correctly best
practices and what not so we preach hey
go further from Shore if you have the
opportunity but not everybody has that
opportunity some Blakes are smaller some
LS are bigger some are stuck in Coes and
200 fet as far as they can go our goal
with this bill is to never have somebody
be banned or restricted from their lake
that is the number one goal of the nire
Marine TR Association it's not to sell
boats anything is a people have boats
and have the right to go boting support
that 200 fet again is a standard is a
minimum people will surf at 300 feet
they'll surf at 400 feet they'll surf at
1,000 feet they'll put their waves and
focus them away from the shoreline
because we teach them that every person
that buys a boat gets an orientation and
the time in the boat it teaches them
best
practices um we've heard a lot about
water Clarity today also and I'm going
to tell you a little story uh I've Had
The Good Fortune to live um on the water
my mother and had a property water and
my goal when I was a kid was to run off
my dock as fast as I possibly could dive
into the water and swim as far as I
could under W my eyes open last summer
in about July there was a significant
rain event and I was at my mom's house
thought I'd do the same thing ran off
our dock soon as far as I could open my
water and the minute my eyes opened up
it was
brown Alton Bay is very clear that's
what her home is exceptionally Clear
Water it was brown I didn't know where I
was there was the rain event bark mulch
dirt everything washed into Al Bay and
ALT Bay was brown for two weeks and
during those two weeks of that same time
there was a significant cob bacteria
Bloom at the end of Alton Bay at a place
called downing's Landing which is a boat
ramp and basically at end of all Bay is
a funnel there's a river that feeds into
it it's all hilly and the all comes down
so all that
sedimentation fertilizer whatever you
want to call it ran into this no wake
zone which is about 400 feet long and
created a c of bacteria Bloom there's no
wake surfing in that area it's a no wake
zone so my point is this is that if
there's no wake surfing boats you can't
point to a wake surf boat and saying
that it caused a bloom at the end of
Alton Bay Where The Boat Ramp was and
didn't also cause the whole lake or
Alton Bay I should say to turn brown I
mean it was brown brown like that wall
you couldn't
see so those are the things I want to
point on today funny little story at the
end of this my daughter loves loons and
my dad passed away in 2008 he was the
sole or one of the primary sponsors of
the education of Border safety back in
2000 I'm going to guess I probably 1997
and I was 16 years old so we joke about
my dad being reincarnated as a loon so
one day we were out wake surfing my
daughter fell and we're kind of hanging
around she's Gathering herself to get up
again and all of a sudden the loom pops
up next to our boat wanted to see what
was going on we all kind of laughed and
said oh there scle mic so loons seemed
to be you know smart creatures this one
came right up to us and looked at our
Bel and said hey this looks like fun
maybe that's ironic I don't know um
again we we support this bill 20 feet is
a great minimum standard allow the New
Hampshire Marine trades to continue to
preach our wake responsibly campaign
educate consumers and do all the things
that we've done since 1996 that b
education has improved and all the
things that can happen better for our
Lakes let's not make it worse let's that
make it restrictive I love people to
have fun with their families and both
safely and smart thank
you any questions by members of the
committee representative Derby followed
by
representative thank thank you Mr chair
thank you um for taking my question
there's been some criticism about the um
about the Marine trade study and so I
was um wondering if you wanted to
respond with criticism about the other
studies reference for example by the UN
University of Michigan study or um
responses to the criticism of the Marine
trade study itself you want to give any
feedback on that again this isn't the
Marine trade study um we're all going to
have an opinion on this we're all all
going to poke holes in this study and
that study and someone's going to say
the sky is blue today but someone's
going to say the clouds are out too um I
think we're all working for the same
goal you know we want to find a balance
we want to find a compromise 200 feet we
are compromising the state of New
Hampshire has 150 foot setback or a safe
passage some things have none let's just
imagine that right now in the state of
New Hampshire we had a zero safe passes
off well 200 feet is a pretty good
balance right everyone can they want to
complain it's only 50 feet it's only 50
feet because we have a safe passage of
150 Florida has zero for my knowledge so
200 ft is a great compromise you know
people wanted to say last in
2022 uh there was a bill that was
focused on
250 and then I think that same week if I
recall correctly the Minnesota study
came out and threw that out the window
and everyone to amend 250 to 500 you
know next year could be a th in two
years it could be a 2,000 now with the
Marine trades feels as though we're
compromising at 200 regardless of the
150t safe passage again that was passed
long time go but big boats have been on
these Lakes for a long time I welcome
anyone to come to Silver Sands Marina
I'd be happy to take you out and give
you a tour over the lake and see our one
of the 60 foot boats it's a privately
own boat uh the 40 foot boats people
live on in our Marina uh the Sophie sea
the DOR sea
their commercial tourism boats to go out
those throw the biggest lake around if
you go behind any one of those for the
afternoon you're going to
find people with jet skis and personal
watercraft jumping those waves they make
the biggest wave on the lake
regardless of the Wake ball
wave for a
followup thank you Mr chair I was
wondering if um if your group has done
any analysis on the difference between
for example 200 and 300 feet and the um
and any lakes that would
not allow wake surfing because of that
additional 100 feet we have not okay
thank
you any anyone else questions seeing
none oh yeah I'm sorry no I I miss
you thank you Mr Welling and thank you
Mr chairman um I don't think it's an
issue of whether wake Vats cause
erosion I think it's an
incremental change you believe
that could you expand on your question
I'm happy to answer I just don't quite
understand if you're we you going sorry
I
don't what is your opinion on the
various causes is each cause create
more
turbidity more more ground stuff that
you couldn't see sure I mean that's the
question is is it incremental
is the Wake boat going to cause some
erosion how could it not in some
capacity just like a boat just like
someone pulling an anchor just like
someone like we we had a conversation
about this at one point you know uh if
you pull into a dock at a reasonable
amount of speed on a rough day and you
got to kind of set your boat between the
two dock posts or whatnot and you got to
put it in reverse you're going to turn
the bottom up I mean it's just how the
water is if you liveing a dock that has
10 feet of water you're not going to do
it if you have a dock that has three
feet of water you're going to have some
some sem of sediment that's going to get
churned up whether it's sand or pine
needles or leaves or or anything we had
a customer years ago uh we worked on
this boat put it in the water and he
took it home and he called this irate my
boat's overheating again and boat's cool
water from the inside of the lake
through their engines well as it
happened and all he did was turned his
boat
on he pulled all these Dead Leaves From
The Bottom up into his
call the intake of his boat it clogged
the intake it didn't allow fresh water
to cool the engine so we were fixing it
again and he hadn't gone anywhere
because the sediment or the leaves or
whatever you want to say it was clogged
this motor so there's always going to be
some aspect of erosion whether it's wind
driven waves that we talked about in the
past um boats
waves there's a multitude of things and
the PIN
less than I would say I'm I'm I'm
estimating so bear with me on this one
don't go look it up because I don't know
if it's even be found but this less than
2% of our boting registrations in the
state of New Hampshire that awakes our
boats it's not a lot I mean it sounds
like it nothing but it's it's not a lot
and there's 98% of other boats out there
that are doing other things it's like
when you drive a cart on the road I mean
an 18-wheeler is going to do more damage
to a road than a passenger car it weighs
more this is something to think
about follow up all right for follow up
but that I want to see this go back and
forth back and forth this is fun right
okay one more round okay go
ahead what is a safe passage with a
water ski
boat safe passeng with the water ski B
you're telling is 150 feet from Shore to
the best of my
knowledge now water skier from my
understanding can drop the rope and they
need to be also set 150 ft from Shore
personal or SK craft two passengers or
one passenger required in the C Hamshire
be 300t from Shore
um is that the right answer I don't know
that's what I've been told that's how
I've read it for years because it's one
of the questions well I guess you 150
thief from a dock or from a raft or from
Shore it's when everything's in the
water a person in the water now expands
the 150 foot setback for off a
Shore I believe that
the distance from Shore to water ski
has to be 300 ft I believe you're
incorrect but we can look that up we
have we have if just I I'm driving for
the question all right if that is in
fact correct how does that impact wake
quats if that is in fact correct when
I'm going to make this some statement
that we don't know the answer to that
question but if it's impact and quick
and wake boats are they're all Breaking
the Law if that is correct at 300 ft
because if that is the law water skiing
tubing anyone but if we have safe
passenger in 150 feet is a safe passage
I believe 150 is the actual law maybe be
done leaving sorry about that maybe he
can expand on that answer
fars that's how I've treated it 150 ft
from
sh haven't been pulled over
yet are is your uh okay shut your light
representative rum thank you Mr chair
thank you Mr Wally for taking my
question um several people have
testified today that they consider this
bill to be baby steps and that that was
the word I believe uh representative
Dolan used like let's let's pass it see
how it goes and if we need to change it
if in the future if this bill passes and
it's shown that we need a greater
distance from Shore to be protective of
the environment and to Lear bons would
you support that I'm going to speak to
the 200 foot stepback is how we stand
okay that's what we support again
because we do not want to see
restrictions or bans I question to how
do we establish a need for it because
the people that don't want to have a
wake boat on the lake now at 200 300
500,000 feet aren't going to be happy
with 200 next week if this passes it's
just history so far
seeing no further questions
seeing all right I'm wondering if we're
gonna have an opportunity to ask um
Captain D leevy questions yes who
Captain D Ley questions uh if he if if
he wishes to
speak okay I mean I will ask him if he
wishes to speak if he doesn't then he
doesn't have to
like but since he's grabbing
a you guys finish the car let's finish
with this
gentleman anything
else thank you very much thank you all
for your time on this matter too uh this
is important to us at the Marine trades
and uh your time your patience your
questions your education we do
appreciate it so thank you and we'll see
you
soon all do you want to i s somebody
also wave a pink card having it having
it there doesn't help you get the P you
got to pass it
up pass it up and you might pass it up
and I'll call you otherwise I don't even
know your name except you're the man
without the
car all right
and right now uh we have all right first
last time Gary York you here Gary York
you know Gary yor car he's he's
gone uh Jody rimless you don't want to
be not you're right thank you very much
all
right all
right all right well I got Captain Don
is coming but uh I'll I'll take Captain
dony because you're actually ask this
question first and then
I'll go with the thank you Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee my
name is Tim Dunley I come before you
today representing the Marine Patrol and
uh I sense that there are some questions
uh the department of safety uh is taking
the position of being neutral on this
bill uh but I am happy to any answer any
technical questions you may have if uh
you wish all
right representative Derby for a
technical
question do you believe I have only
technical questions thank you so much Mr
J thank you you uh Captain D Ley for
taking my question um can you explain
how the best practices for the um uh
that's referenced in the uh Senate bill
will be um will be determined um how
they how public will be educated about
them and the ability for public input in
determining those best
practices well certainly uh best
practices are going to be considered
from a safety perspective for our course
uh if we have laws to enforce we will we
will uh educate the public on the laws
that exist uh we talk about best
practices when it comes to loading a
boat at the boat ramp best practices
when it comes to uh Designated Drivers
and and the consumption of alcohol there
are many examples of best practices so
uh we are doing that now um from a
general perspective uh if there is a
specific law that needs to be enforced
uh and that the public needs to be
informed of that'll be included in our
curriculum if that answers your
question I I didn't thank you very much
I didn't hear the can I follow apologies
um Mr chair I didn't hear the part is
there any opportunity for public input
to
that there is uh but that that leaves
the department of safety sort of in a
conundrum if if the public in general is
disagreeing about what those practices
are um um so we will look at it with an
eye towards safety uh if it comes down
to that would be my guess and in any
direction that the commissioner's office
would uh would want us to take we
would for third and last
time I thought this was only second but
thank you Mr okay um first two and a
half times I was wondering if you could
comment on um evaluating the distance of
200 versus 300 feet both by um you know
the recreational boater that has to try
to comply with this law as well as by
Marine Patrol that would have to enforce
the
law uh distance judging distances is
part of our not only our officer
training but part of our public courses
um the 150 foot distance which many of
you have been hearing about uh we we
actually if the weather is conducive to
it we actually take our students out
into a parking lot we stretch out a a
line a rope that is 150 ft so that the
students can see those distances uh
we'll do it at 75 ft um the public is
often times reminded that the majority
of the ski lines the toll lines that you
buy in the marinas to water ski is 75 ft
in length unless it's been altered um
for traditional water skiing um 150 ft
is half a football field if you've
played soccer or played football uh
you've been out on these fields you have
a rough idea about how how long they are
and if you've done any wind Sprints
under a coach that takes advantage of
that you know the distance fairly well
uh a person oftentimes is very familiar
with the length of their boat as well
when they go to pull into a town dock
it's like pulling your car into a
parking lot at the grocery store you
know what kind of width you need for
your vehicle you know what kind of
length you needed to town do for your
boat and if you know your boat's 25 ft
well then you know you're looking at six
both lengths to get to 150 ft um our
Marine Patrol curriculum includes
something as basic as a line it also
includes laser radar uh we do Boat tobo
Boat to shore dock to Boat Boat to swim
float all those uh measurements are um
included in our curriculum uh we have
the 150t distance for um General boating
at greater than Headway speed from dock
rafts swim floats moing fields and the
shoreline and we have a distance of 300
ft from Shore for the operation of a ski
craft a ski craft is the two person
personal
watercraft um and we include those
distances in that curriculum as
well okay you have one I I very um Mr
chair I very much appreciate this I
promise this will be my I think my last
question of the day um I was wondering
if you could explain to the committee
the difference between wake surfing and
wake boarding and um how wake boarding
is covered in current
statute uh the the difference between
the two uh from a safety perspective
requires the same
equipment um wake boarding is something
that typically you're attached to the
boat with a rope a toe line and wake
surfing you do not uh but the safety
equipments that is required for the the
surfer or the border is is the same life
jacket wear time of day that type of
thing
all thank you so much for the rest of
the year no more
questions I think you got that
one
um someone else wake surfing is in
statute and wake boarding is not in
Statue so how is wake boarding covered
um in Statue I understand your question
it's a good one uh wake boarding uh
falls under the definition of water
skiing where uh the term that's used in
statute is a pertinence that's being
towed by the boat uh and so therefore
it's covered by the general term of
water
skiing all right uh representative wolf
you have a question thank you thank you
C has to do with length of skiing
SK ski what does it have to do with the
skiing how far does ski ski ski skcraft
operating you said have to be 300 feet
from Shore yes sir before they can go
greater than Headway speed yes
sir
so thank you 300 ft yes
sir all
right this isn't a this isn't a question
for Derby is
it okay I'm just making
certain I should know the answer to this
Captain dunlevy but with your response
to to representive wolves about they
have to be three water skiers and I
guess border you know the the surf
borders have to be 300 feet from Shore
until unless they're under Headway speed
and is Headway speed defined that's
defined as going
you can't you you you can moving forward
without having to use steerage is that
correct um you're close uh respectfully
uh Headway speed is the slowest speed
that you can travel with your boat and
maintain safe steerage not to go over
six miles per hour so it and it's
synonymous with the term no
wake okay is Headway speed right follow
up Mr chair so all right this is it okay
my last question of it has specifically
to do with this bill all right so if a
wake boat is Towing someone okay but
they'd have to be 300 feet from Shore
unless they're not creating a
wake not a wake booat a ski craft which
is a jet ski oh okay the two person ski
craft is defined as um a two-person
device I got you uh most people call Jet
Skis yeah a ski craft is not a boat
towing water
skiers oh okay that's good to know all
right any other further questions no
thank you very much thank you for your
time and thank you and uh Miss Rick is
it
Tuttle
okay wish to speak two minutes
I'm here representing myself basically
but I'd like to think that I represent a
large and growing group of kayakers uh
I've
been kayaking for 36 years now 1988 I
first started and uh I would never go
back to any other craft it's uh and in
that time I've seen a lot of uh problems
out on the water and um when I read the
U this bill it uh reminded me of
a of a bad experience I had but uh that
has nothing to do with this bill but um
my my biggest problem with this bill is
in the safety aspect of it uh the safety
aspect we're looking at presently 150 ft
if I'm not mistaken and they want to
take it to 200 feet uh representative
wolf I'm sorry he left uh he had a
question earlier on from somebody else
that asked him would it make a
difference safety-wise to add 50 feet to
this bill and initially you think 50
feet is nothing therefore no it
shouldn't make any difference but
there's a big butt in there any
additional distance would help kayakers
because it's not the initial boat going
by that we're worried about most of the
time it is the fact that that wake
follows that boat maybe a few minutes
maybe five minutes
later and if you're not prepared for it
it sneaks up on you big time and when
that happens you can easily be thrown
right over when that happens you're in
big de big deep trouble literally deep
trouble because you have to rescue
yourself and you have to rescue your
boat and you have to rescue the contents
of it um I was speak from experience
that way because I had a boat go past me
once at a close
distance and he did not slow down it
swamped my boat 2third full of water and
luckily I'm a wildlife photographer so I
carry around a couple of thousand
dollars worth of gear in my boat at any
given time luckily I had put my camera
and lens into my dry bag less than 5
minutes
earlier without that I would have been
out 2,000 bucks so in that respect I am
I'm very uh sensitive to the safety
aspect of it so I want to see more
distance I would support this bill if it
went to 300 feet I think I've seen I've
heard a lot of uh uh people asking that
question
and I think that makes a
difference but likewise if we don't make
a change to that bill if we don't
increase that
distance the well I think everybody
agrees now that
uh climate change is a factor so if we
wait two years storms get worse look at
the storms we had on the coast this year
no doubt those were some of the worst
storms we've ever suffered in the state
if that happens two years from now how
bad are they going to be and if we don't
make those increases to the distance how
bad is the erosion going to be how bad
is the safety aspect going to be of
people that have houses near those lines
the red Lakes are not often um really
subject to the uh the storm surges that
we got at the coast but the fact is you
get a heavy enough storm and you get
enough wind yes it will blow it in and
that comes in my next uh my second of
two concerns people are saying well it's
uh it's a factor of a storm comes up and
if you have a really bad storm then
that's a force of nature yes it is
nature will recover from its own storms
but if we don't give nature a choice of
or a chance to be able to recover from
the those storms we're just going to
continue to go
downhill what I mean by that is during
the winter months we have sever storms
during the during the severe storms
they're mostly during the winter
and very little is growing you look at
the growth uh plant life and animal life
it's in recess we'll say come summertime
it starts to grow back if it grows back
that's great it's recovering from the
damage that the winter
created if we continue to have more
boats out there creating more damage
along the shoreline it never gets a
chance to recover it's as simple as
that that's all I'd like to say so okay
thank you very
much okay thank you all
right having no further pink
cards and I don't think anybody else
wants I don't see anyone waving any pink
cards I will declare the uh the hearing
adjourned yes I just have a question of
procedure for who procedure procedure
process we
have in this committee as I understand
it
two
choices we can accept the Senate Bill
yep or we can amend the Senate
Bill if we you could also uh study it if
you wanted
to or defeat or defeat
it if we interim study it has to go back
to the Senate no does not go back to the
C it does not go back to the go back to
it becomes a it becomes interim study
interim study and and it and it dies on
December 6 right there is we have we it
has a
uh we do a study where we we we sub we
submit a report to the uh to the
house and if it goes to the Senate the
Senate does not have to Concur and the
bill would die if we amend it and send
it to the if you amend it the Senate the
Senate has three has three
choices it can concur it cannot Concur
and it cannot Concur and respect and
request the committee of conference that
is their choice that
chance okay thank
you anyone else
question if not I'll adjourn the this
this hearing I do need at
least three
BLS say okay all
right I will do
539 where's he going
uh for